[Musique]
[Rires]
bonsoir à tous il est 22h nous sommes en
direct sur Public Sénat pour suivre
l'examen de la réforme des retraites au
Sénat Public Sénat qui bouleverse sa
grille des programmes pour suivre au
plus près ces débats d'ailleurs je vous
signale que vous pouvez lire les
décryptages de nos journalistes sur
notre site web je vous donne l'adresse
et SF fiche c'est bien sûr Public Sénat
point fr alors ces discussions à l'heure
où l'on se parle ou en sont-elles vers
18h aujourd'hui les sénateurs ont entamé
l'examen des amendements il y en a
encore exactement au moment où je vous
parle
3669 à examiner le rythme de croisière
des sénateurs et de 30 amendements
examinés par heure et on en est toujours
aux amendements sur l'article liminaire
c'est-à-dire l'article introductif à la
réforme pour en parler on va rejoindre
notre journaliste Audrey vuettaz qui
scrute tous ces débats depuis la tribune
de presse de l'hémicycle bonsoir Audrey
dites-nous tout de ce qui se passe la
gauche en quelque sorte une obstruction
cordiale c'est ça qui se passe en ce
moment et oui Quentin les échanges sont
toujours très cordiaux mais les
sénateurs de gauche déploie
tranquillement leur tactique en
utilisant tous les moyens mis à leur
disposition dans le règlement du Sénat
pour ralentir les débats en réalité il
ne souhaite pas que l'article 7 celui
sur l'allongement de l'âge de départ en
retraite soit voté avant la grande
journée de mobilisation du 7 mars
justement ils ont donc déposé quatre
motions fait une dizaine de rappels au
règlement c'est moins qu'à l'Assemblée
nationale mais c'est tout de même
beaucoup pour le Sénat Quentin ça a
continué avec le dépôt de près d'une
soixantaine d'amendements pour supprimer
l'article liminaire le préambule une
soixantaine d'amendements à raison de
deux minutes par amendement il y a eu
deux heures de débat rien que sur ce
sujet alors le Sénat à majorité de
droite a su à rejeter l'idée de
supprimer cet article liminaire résultat
il est 22h les débats ont repris depuis
un petit quart d'heure encore quelques
amendements Quentin et on devrait se
diriger tranquillement vers l'examen de
l'article 1 celui sur la suppression des
régimes spéciaux et bien merci Audrey
merci pour tous ces explications vous
l'avez vu à l'image c'est la centriste
Valérie Létard qui préside cette séance
depuis la reprise à 21h45 sans plus
attendre je vous propose de rejoindre
l'hémicycle pour suivre ses bornes en
direct
et c'est plus juste que je suis assez
d'accord c'est plus juste de dire récent
sénateur
[Musique]
et donc pour un sénateur récemment
installé j'ai entendu avec bonheur
l'ensemble de ces bancs défendre souvent
face au gouvernement la sincérité des
débats et l'exigence du travail bien
fait pour le Sénat et dans ce texte nous
nous appuyons donc sur des
orientations qui n'ont pas été validées
celle du projet de loi de programmation
moi je ne sais d'ailleurs pas qu'elles
sont pas ce qu'elles sont puisque ici
dans cette armistique nous avons voté la
suppression de 120 000 emplois de
fonctionnaires enfin nous vous avez voté
chers collègues à droite la suppression
de 120 000 emplois de fonctionnaires et
je ne les retrouve pas dans les tableaux
c'est 120 000 emplois supprimés je ne
retrouve pas dans les tableaux et comme
ensuite le texte n'a pas été adopté je
ne sais pas quel est le texte qui reste
en course mais deuxième remarque
vous n'acceptez pas monsieur le ministre
du socle de communiquer au parlementaire
la note de synthèse du Conseil d'État
certains de mes collègues vont penser
que je suis redondant
c'est pas faux
c'est pas faux mais je m'attendais à ce
que sur vos bancs aussi on demande cette
note de synthèse du Conseil d'État ça
fait partie de la bonne information des
parlementaires et de la sincérité des
débats et entendre un ministre nous dire
que toute façon c'est connu il suffit de
lire les journaux ne me paraît pas
respectueux du travail parlementaire
merci la parole à Monsieur ça vole Delhi
et on clôturera par la prise par le
monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente sur les
ministres mes chers collègues je suis
Attal je viens de retrouver vos propos à
l'Assemblée nationale
dixit je vous cite me fait pas perdre de
temps il y a toujours un projet de loi
de programmation des finances publiques
ne vous en déplaise et ce n'est pas très
respect que du Sénat que de considérer
que quand le Sénat vote un texte cela
signifie rien
et bah ici on est où cela donc le Sénat
il a modifié le projet de loi et il la
durci dedans il y avait la suppression
des 120 000 fonctionnaires qui n'a pas
été retenu et il y avait d'autres
aspects vous en tenez pas compte dans
les propositions vous nous faites là ici
on est au Sénat et les sénateurs ont
rejeté en CMP vous en tenez pas compte
non plus alors oui il y a un projet de
loi de programmation des finances
publiques je sais pas où il est on en a
il n'y a pas accès ici on n'y a pas
droit on n'y a pas droit à qu'on soit de
la majorité ou de l'opposition il n'y a
pas droit je parle dans quel tiroir il
est mis et j'ai regardé comment vous
fondez vos décisions sur comment vous
interpréter les décisions du Conseil
constitutionnel du 29 décembre 2022 qui
aurait je cite son considérant 23 et là
je le cite monsieur le ministre je cite
en l'espèce le tableau de synthèse de
l'article liminaire de la loi de finance
pour les 2023 reprend les prévisions
présentées dans le projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour les années 2023 2027 si ce projet
de loi de programmation qui a été déposé
sur le bureau de l'Assemblée nationale
le même jour que le projet de loi de
finance n'a pas été adopté avant
l'adoption de la loi de finances pour
2023 il ne résulte de cette circonstance
aucune méconnaissance de l'article
premier âge de la loi organique du
premier août 2001 ni du principe de
clarté et du principe de sincérité du
débat parlementaire donc les choses sont
claires on travaille dans quelles
conditions ici avec quel respect des
travaux parlementaires franchement et
puis tout à l'heure sur la question vous
choisissez sénateur symbole d'Elie un
passage de ce que dit le Haut Conseil ça
voyez ça on choisit pas moi je choisis
pas parce que sont les avis du Conseil
d'État du Conseil publicitaire etc je
choisis pas je prends merci merci
monsieur le ministre
non très rapidement pour la clarté des
débats parce que c'est important pour
répondre monsieur Breuillet d'abord je
vous rassurer moi je crois profondément
que la jeunesse est un état d'esprit et
j'ai appris tout à l'heure par Madame
Rossignol que j'étais un vieux tas de
syrien donc ça veut dire que vous pouvez
être un jeune sénateur
ensuite
ensuite ensuite je veux vous préciser
puisque c'est une question que vous avez
posée de clarté c'est bien par rapport
au projet de loi initial déposée par le
gouvernement sur la loi de programmation
des finances publiques que ce fond de
cet article liminaire puisque le texte
est encore dans la navette parlementaire
donc les écarts qui sont mesurés dans
l'article luminaire c'est par rapport au
projet de loi initial et oui monsieur ça
boldelli vous avez lu vous-même le
considérant 23 de la décision du 29
décembre 2022 du Conseil constitutionnel
qui dit très clairement qu'un texte
financier peut tout à fait se référer à
un projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques non encore adopté
sans que ça n'ait aucun impact sur la
sincérité des débats et que ça ça n'ait
aucun n'a aucun impact sur le respect la
loi organique mais c'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est le Conseil constitutionnel je
le enfin on le respecte tous je crois et
enfin pour répondre à Monsieur Raynal
l'an dernier recette d'impôt sur les
sociétés historiques 62 milliards
d'euros en 2006 l'année que vous avez
prise en prix en référence je crois que
c'était entre combien
45 en 2006 le taux à l'époque était à
33% on avait 45 aujourd'hui le taux est
à 25% on a 62 donc c'est plutôt positif
et sur France stratégie je veux pas
allonger les débats on n'est pas en PLF
évidemment mais France stratégie rapport
très intéressant sur le prélèvement
forfaitaire unique la flat taxe ils
disent quoi que la flat tax se
prélèvement forfaitaire unique c'est
autofinancé puisque le fait qu'on est
baissé les impôts a fait que l'activité
économique s'est développée que les
recettes supplémentaires ont compensé la
baisse du taux donc c'est plutôt positif
aussi du point de vue de France
stratégie
merci Monsieur le Ministre j'ai été
saisi
que publicain sur les trois amendements
identiques de 1625
3402 3813 je vous rappelle que l'avis de
la commission est défavorable la vie du
gouvernement défavorable il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert
[Musique]
voilà vous êtes en train d'assister à un
scrutin public au Sénat ça signifie
qu'au lieu de voter à main levée les
sénateurs vont voter grâce à des cartes
de vote électromagnétique sur leur
pupitre c'est souvent utilisé c'est ce
scrutin public pour rallonger aussi la
durée des débats puisque lieu de
simplement voter en levant la main et
bien il y a toute une une démarche comme
cela ou on interrompt les débats pour
donner le temps à tous les sénateurs de
voter donc on va voir aussi dans cette
obstruction cordiale comme on le dit et
depuis 17h et bien certains groupes
politiques utilisés ce scrutin public
pour ralentir là encore elle est débat
le scrutin public permet également
d'avoir la cartographie prestige de qui
a voté quoi et donc lorsque l'on va
retourner dans l'hémicycle dans quelques
secondes on va avoir comme ça la carte
entière de l'hémistique
[Musique]
pour 91 contre 252 c'est trois
amendements ne sont pas adoptés
le
200627 a reçu deux avis favorables même
vote
défavorable pardon même vote
même votre
2626 de avis défavorables même vote
[Musique]
votez alors deux avis défavorables qui
pour
qui contre
qui s'obtient
il n'est pas adopté
3806 deux avis des favorables qui pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté 4
qui le défend madame
assassin il est défendu
[Musique]
on se calme comme dirait l'autre ça va
bien se passer vous inquiétez pas
donc nous considérons que l'expression
d'être au sens de maastrichtant à
invisibiliser le caractère contraignant
d'un traité européen en l'occurrence
celui de Maastricht qui parle la
coordination de politique économique
c'est-à-dire l'article 121 et la formule
lapidaire de l'artiste 126 je cite les
États membres évitent les déficits
explicits consacrent le jeu des
institutions européennes à l'instar des
décisions nationales en matière de
dépenses publiques
je vous l'ai dit ça va bien se passer
[Musique]
donc cette réforme des retraites
il convient de la rappeler et de le
rappeler émane d'une volonté européenne
de réduction de la dépense publique dont
c'est amendement permet de ne pas
omettre la Genèse wallicy le sens de cet
amendement merci madame la Présidente
avis de la commission sur le 4478
oui
madame la Présidente assassy la vie de
la commission est défavorable moi je
reconnais votre envie de faire les
choses très très bien votre perspic
votre envie d'être perspicace mais
changer ma Street je pars traité de
Maastricht je pense que en fait le sens
il est là à Maastricht tout le monde
comprend et donc est-ce que ça vaut le
coup finalement de prolonger la navette
sur cet article je ne le pense pas
merci même la rapporteur monsieur le
ministre défavorable
alors madame Monsieur Laurent d'abord
madame rossignols
[Musique]
non mais écoutez ça n'est pas une
réponse la question c'est de poser et de
savoir s'il faut qu'on maintenir dans
tous les textes budgétaires cette
formule la dette au sens de Maastricht
les critères de Maastricht tout le monde
les connaît ils ont volé en éclat avec
la pandémie il y a plus aucun pays
européen qui les respecte donc les
critères de Maastricht ne sont pas
respectés en Europe actuellement plus
personne ne parle de la règle des trois
pourcents et d'ailleurs le pack
budgétaire est suspendu et personne à ma
connaissance ne connaît les règles
futures puisqu'elles sont en négociation
à moins que le gouvernement les ai
décidés tout seul sans ses partenaires
européens donc pour le moment les règles
de la dette au sens de maastrisme on ne
sait pas ce que ça veut dire par
ailleurs nous savons aujourd'hui que le
calcul sur lequel reposait ça était
parfaitement artificiel je vous prends
des chiffres la dette publique au sens
de Maastricht comme vous dit elle
s'élève en 2021 à 112 % ennemis du PIB
mais au sens de l'Insee les mêmes
chiffres c'est 101 point de du PIB et au
sens de d'Eurostat et de l'OCDE c'est 87
% du PIB donc en fait il y a des bas sur
ces critères vous continuez de les
utiliser comme un dogme qu'ils étaient
au départ alors qu'ils n'ont plus de
sens aujourd'hui surtout dans la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes donc
c'est ça la question que nous posons
vous continuez d'agiter ce dogme pour
justifier la compression des dépenses en
faveur des retraites alors qu'en vérité
ces règles elles ont volé en éclat
aujourd'hui merci monsieur le président
madame la Présidente
je pense que certains d'entre nous
peut-être beaucoup vont cet amendement
mais je voulais juste revenir sur
l'argument qui avait été donné par la
rapporteur qui disait qu'il ne fallait
pas changer d'aide de masse riche par
dette du traité de Maastricht parce que
ça risquait de ralentir
inutilement la navette et j'ai un doute
sur la je crois que c'est pas tout
compris en fait sur ce qui se passe en
ce moment dès lors qu'il n'y a pas eu à
l'Assemblée nationale d'adoption de ce
texte
quelle navette pourrait être ralentie
par le fait que nous votons un
amendement et je voudrais savoir si cet
amendement ralentirait plus la navette
que les amendements que vous allez
proposer tout à l'heure à l'article 2
sur les régimes spéciaux alors que
l'article 2 a été rejeté à l'assemblée
qui risque aussi de retarder la navette
donc qu'est-ce que la navette vient
faire un Maastricht dans cet article là
je ne n'ai pas compris mais on votera
l'amendement quand même parce que
l'amendement je l'ai compris merci chers
collègues la parole est à Madame linman
oui chers collègues le terme de
deathmastrichienne n'a pas de sens
je vous rappelle que le traité de
Maastricht ne fait fixer pas des
critères durables c'était des critères
de convergence dont la fin de vie de ces
critères obligatoires était le passage à
l'euro
et c'est le traité d'Amsterdam
qui redéfinit le cadre du Pacte de
Stabilité
donc les critères de dette ne sont pas
définis dans le tri critères de
Maastricht puisqu'ils étaient caduques
au moment du passage à l'euro mais ceux
d'Amsterdam ce n'est pas neutre
politiquement car tous ceux qui ont voté
Maastricht n'ont pas nécessairement voté
le traité d'Amsterdam une chose était de
converger une autre était de mettre dans
le dogme des traités des critères
macroéconomiques qui devraient relever
de l'arbitrage politique
mais je voudrais dire un autre point
c'est que un des critères qui n'est
jamais soulevé
et qui devrait pourtant être soulevé par
la France vis-à-vis de l'Allemagne
c'est le critère de balance de balance
commerciale excessive il était prévu
dans les traités que si un pays de
l'Union avait une balance commerciale
excessivement forte au regard de la
moyenne il devait prendre des mesures de
relance intérieure pour justement
rééquilibrer la donne notamment en
matière d'échange industriel
j'observe que la France n'a jamais eu le
courage de demander le respect de ces
critères en tout cas ils ne sont pas de
Maastricht mais du traité d'Amsterdam
merci chers collègues je vais haut voit
l'amendement
4478 qu'a reçu deux avis défavorables
qui est pour
[Musique]
qui est contre
qui s'obtient il n'est pas adopté le
3793 madame Brunin
merci madame la Présidente il est
proposé avec cet article dans série une
ligne qui précise les objectifs réels de
cette réforme à savoir contenir la
croissance des dépenses de sécurité
sociale et de retraites à 0,6% afin de
se conformer aux engagements pris auprès
de la Commission européenne de maintenir
une croissance des dépenses publiques à
0,6%. je crois que dans cet article nous
voyons à nouveau je serais tenté de dire
quel est le véritable projet du
gouvernement il ne s'agit pas seulement
de faire travailler plus longtemps les
Françaises et les français pour
soi-disant sauver notre système de
retraite par répartition ni d'améliorer
les petites pensions et encore moins
celui et l'emploi des seniors projets
consiste à reculer l'âge de départ en
retraite pour respecter cela vient
d'être dit la règle des 3% qui ne
correspond plus à grand chose dans
l'époque où nous sommes la même
austérité qui a conduit les
gouvernements successifs par exemple à
ne pas remplacer des départs en retraite
dans la fonction publique et qui a
déséquilibré les finances des retraites
justifient aujourd'hui de nouvelles
régressions sociales cela fait près de
10 ans que la Commission européenne
demande à la France de réformer le
système de retraite et de reculer l'âge
de départ
aujourd'hui c'est en contrepartie du
plan de relance européen accord qui a
doté de 40 milliards pour la France que
le gouvernement s'engage à réduire à la
fois les droits à l'assurance sauvage et
à réformer notre système de retraite je
rappelle que le projet de loi de finance
pour 2023 a supprimé entre autres la
cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises qui constituaient une
ressource essentielle pour les
collectivités territoriales puisqu'elle
a représenté en 2021 5,7 milliards
d'euros pour le blog communal et 3,8
pour les départements d'ici à 2024 ce
sont 16 milliards d'euros en moins pour
les entreprises et l'État soit
exactement le montant du déficit du
système dressif le gouvernement je vous
remercie
la parole est à la Commission
oui c'est un avis défavorable parce que
c'est la loi organique qui définit la
forme du tableau vous pouvez pas
rajouter une colonne comme cela merci si
monsieur le ministre
je vous remercie explication de votre
madame Cohen
donc merci madame la Présidente deux ans
de plus donc deux ans de vie volée qui
doivent permettre de réduire les
dépenses de retraite pour te dire les
engagements du gouvernement à respecter
le totem du 3 % du déficit public ce
fameux 3% dont les économies s'accordent
à dire qu'il ne correspond à aucun
indicateur économique sérieux la règle
du 3% qui justifie toutes les
régressions sociales depuis 30 ans est
né sur un coin de table mes chers
collègues récemment l'ancien haut
fonctionnaire de la direction du budget
qui en est à l'origine précisément un
journal
iste sur n'a aucune réflexion théorique
alors pourquoi 3% lorsque 1000 en 1982
le président de la République de
l'époque François Mitterrand rencontre
des difficultés économiques avec un
déficit qui atteint les 100 milliards de
francs il a demandé à ses conseillers de
trouver un chiffre au pourcentage plus
accessible après avoir hésité avec 2%
c'est le chiffre de 3% pour le maximum
du déficit public qui a été retenu c'est
ensuite un certain Laurent Fabius
ministre des Finances qui a repris ce
chiffre avant lui-même d'être pris dans
le traité de Maastricht devenant un des
critères pour pouvoir intégrer la zone
euro ainsi donc parce qu'il y a 40 ans
le chiffre de 3% a été retenu et pas
celui de 4% par exemple vous allez
sacrifier deux années de vie à nos
concitoyennes et nos concitoyens votre
réforme comptable de trompes personnes
ni les 9 organisations syndicales de
salariés ni les trois quarts des
Français ni les 93% d'actifs qui
s'opposent à votre coup de force et qui
seront présents je peux encore vous le
rappeler une nouvelle fois si vous
n'avez pas enregistré la date le 7 mars
merci Madame Cohen madame linman
oui chers collègues en effet le chiffre
des 3% est un chiffre qui est sorti un
peu du chapeau il fallait en trouver un
comme je vous l'avais dit tout à l'heure
ça devait être valable jusqu'au passage
de l'euro et ensuite on doit fonctionner
ce qui est un fonction Mitterrand il
avait toujours expliqué que la deuxième
étape devait être accompagnée d'un
gouvernement économique de la zone euro
qui devait définir le cas de
macroéconomique de manière plus rielle
et c'est Jacques Chirac son gouvernement
qui a négocié le traité d'Amsterdam sans
introduire l'arbitrage un gouvernement
économique en reprenant pure sucre ce
qui était des critères de convergence
pour être des critères advita eternam et
ça pèse très lourd parce que ça a été
une façon une vision malthusienne du
développement de l'Union européenne je
rappelle que depuis cette période la
croissance moyenne en Europe est la plus
faible du continent du monde
plus qu'un qu'aux États-Unis plus fin
que les autres zones donc ces arbitrages
macroéconomiques nous les pesons nous
les ils nous pèsent lourd mais par
ailleurs la Commission non contente de
faire du développement de du déficit
public à ajouter un critère de la baisse
et dépenses publiques
excusez du peu c'est exactement le débat
qu'on a ça veut dire est-ce qu'on
dépense on baisse ça dépense publique ou
est-ce qu'on trouve des recettes pour
limiter le difficile public or la
logique libérale de financiarisation de
la Commission à veiller à dire non
seulement il faut que vous baissiez le
déficit mais la dépense si bien qu'au
sommet de Barcelone il a été écrit noir
sur blanc qu'il fallait baisser la
dépense publique que l'âge moyen des
retraites dans l'Union européenne et ça
c'était en 2002 l'âge moyen de départ en
retrait dans l'Union européenne devait
rapidement atteindre 63,5 années et
qu'il fallait développer les de
capitalisation excusez du peu l'Union
Européenne a matricié une certaine
vision que vous avez dit reprise
pénalise les Français merci
alors pour tout comprendre de ce qui se
joue en ce moment dans l'émission qu'on
va retrouver notre journaliste Audrey
Vettel qui est en tribune de presse de
l'hémicycle Audrey depuis hier sur cette
réforme on a vu plusieurs scrutins
publiques à chaque fois c'est le même
clivage exact qui ressort comment est-ce
qu'on explique ces votes c'est que tout
est déjà arrêté en fait autour de cette
réforme oui c'est vrai Quentin que ce
soit à main levée ou lors de votre
électronique la dynamique reste toujours
la même sur ces amendements déposés par
la gauche on a en général autour de 90
voix pour ce sont les voix de la gauche
et
250 voix compte ce sont le reste des
sénateurs de la droite et du centre vous
le voyez les amendements des fils
déposés par la gauche les votes
s'enchaînent mais chacun semble camper
sur ses positions on reste avec vous
encore quelques secondes Audrey parce
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure un peu
d'énervement autour d'une prise de
parole d'élian SSI vous qui voyez tout
depuis la tribune de presse que s'est-il
passé des choses que vous n'avez
peut-être pas pu voir à l'écran fait
quand la présidente assise a voulu
défendre l'un de ses amendements elle
s'est rendu compte qu'elle n'avait pas
sa feuille on lui a donc fait passer sa
feuille ça a pris un peu de temps ça a
un petit peu agacé dans les rangs de la
droite qui ont poussé quelques Hué elle
leur a répondu avec malice ça va bien se
passer réponse référence pardon à une
citation de Gérald Darmanin on le voit
en l'observe les sénateurs de gauche
font tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour
ralentir les débats un petit exemple ça
fait maintenant 10 minutes qu'on est en
train de débattre s'il faut t'écrire
Maastricht ou Traité de Maastricht dans
l'un des points du texte merci merci
Audrey pour ses explications sans plus
attendre retour au déballant les muscles
en direct
donc nous voterons cet amendement merci
chers collègues
monsieur Savel
merci madame la Présidente semis mes
chers collègues c'est pas un débat de
sémantique c'est un débat politique
qu'on a là y compris toutes les
interventions qui succèdent le montrent
et comme vous avez beaucoup parlé ou pas
assez de la dette publique c'est normal
qu'on s'attarde sur les mots la dette
publique en 2021 a s'élevé monsieur le
ministre a 2813 milliards au sens du
traité de Maastricht
72,5% du PIB
en 2021 monsieur le ministre la dette
publique au sens de l'Insee n'est plus
que de 2522 milliards d'euros soit 101,2
points de PIB et mieux encore en 2021
toujours la dette publique nette au sens
d'eurostate et l'OCDE n'est plus que de
2174 milliards soit 87% du PIB donc ce
qui vient d'être débattu es ce qui a
expliqué la Présidente assassy c'est pas
un tour de passe-passe des sédatrices et
sénateurs communistes
c'est une autre méthode de calcul c'est
pour ça que les mots ont du sens madame
la rapporteur et que c'est pas un
amendement mineur et secondaire parce
qu'il y a une autre méthode de calcul
qui consiste simplement à déduire les
actifs au plus largement la valeur
financière nette pour euro stade et les
engagements financiers net pour le cede
donc il y a une question de logique
c'est pas qu'une question comme ça de
petit mot et de petits amendements parce
que ça nous renvoie quand même à un
niveau de la dette par rapport à notre
PIB voyez à trois calculs différents
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut voter cet
amendement
[Musique]
la parole
merci oui je voulais revenir je trouve
que ce débat soit ma triché est tout à
fait intéressant et sur la façon en fait
de faire ses équilibres c'est le point
qui nous occupe aujourd'hui mais pas
qu'aujourd'hui ça a été rappelé par
Laurence Rossignol c'est vraiment un
enjeu permanent et si on veut revenir
sur quelques sur quelques sujets récents
finalement
à cette difficulté déjà de l'équilibre
on a donc rajouté la volonté de baisser
les impôts dans notre pays dans une
période qui sincèrement de s'y prêtait
pas ça au moins on peut le reconnaître
parce que avec des crises successives
comme nous avons eu est-ce bien le
moment de baisser les impôts alors je ne
reviendrai pas sur l'Impôt sur l'IS ils
m'ont fait la démonstration a été faite
entre 2006 et 2023 il y a donc eu une
augmentation encore heureux c'est même
pas l'inflation si on regarde bien les
choses bon donc restons calme sur le
sujet enfin je vous dirai sur ce point
de l'IS quand même et vous nous le
savons tous tous ceux qui ont dirigé une
entreprise savent que c'est pas parce
qu'on baisse l'impôt sur les sociétés
que l'on a des profits qui augmentent
c'est pas la réalité la belle de l'impôt
sur les sociétés permet éventuellement
d'investir davantage et ensuite ayant
plus investi on peut avoir des bénéfices
donc ce nécessaire tout à fait sans lien
je voudrais dire que c'est la même chose
pour la cbae la cede on a enlevé 20
milliards personne est capable de nous
dire où ils sont passés personne et je
rappelle juste ici que le Parlement a
voté contre à l'Assemblée nationale ils
ne l'ont pas vu et au Sénat nous avons
voté contre et malgré tout la CVAE
continue à être supprimé et donc c'est
un problème parce qu'on pourrait
effectivement là aussi récupérer
facilement quelques milliards c'est une
évidence et personne ne nous a prouvé
pour la première partie des milliers 20
milliards qui ont été supprimés que ça
avait eu quelques filles que ce soit
enfin je termine avec un dernier point
sur quand même le balancier pour les
habitants vous avez d'un côté on a
enlevé la taxe d'habitation
qui n'était pas payée par 30% des moins
aisés de notre pays et de l'autre côté
et bien maintenant on va sanctionner
tout le monde au niveau des retraites
merci Monsieur Président je mets aux
voix l'amendement
3793 qui a reçu deux avis défavorables
qui est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté j'ai été saisie d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe
communicitoyen et républicain sur
l'article liminaire il va être procédé
au scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement
explication de vote oui merci madame la
Présidente oui explication de vote ce
ministre lors des débats l'Assemblée
nationale vous avez eu cette formule un
peu apocalyptique en disant c'est la
réforme ou la faillite
c'était ici
alors je pose cette formule au propos
tenu par le président de du conseil de
l'orientation des retraites monsieur
pierre-louisbra qui dit tranquillement
les dépenses de retraite n'étaient pas
elles sont relativement maîtrisées dans
la plupart des hypothèses elle diminue
plutôt à terre mais dans l'hypothèse
retenue par le gouvernement elle diminue
très très peu mais un peu à terme alors
je vais aussi citer monsieur Brun qui
s'exprimait devant l'Assemblée nationale
en tout cas les commissions des finances
de l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat et
il explique qu'il ne devrait pas y avoir
de sol négatif si les dépenses restent
constantes par rapport au PIB c'est là
où il va y avoir les évolutions qui ne
sont pas intuitives et il explique ce
déficit par trois phénomènes clairs dont
les deux principaux sont les suivants
tout d'abord la baisse des dépenses de
retraite de l'État employeur pour ses
fonctionnaires alors que ces cotisations
représentent 15% de l'ensemble des
cotisations versées quand les
fonctionnaires ne représentent que 8% de
l'emploi total deuxième un effet cnrcl
c'est son expression concrètement une
après j'ai rémunération des fonctions
publiques territoriales et hospitalières
dans les rémunérations totales cette
diminution serait causée tant par une
baisse de rémunération qu'une baisse des
effectifs en résumé le déficit est CRE
usé car ceux qui cotisent le plus quand
ils seront moins en proportion de la
somme des cotisations monsieur ministre
vous pourriez au moins reconnaître que
ce sont bien aussi les restrictions sur
l'emploi public qui génère le déficit
annoncé du système de retraite et vous
pourriez aussi reconnaître que vous
projeter des économies non seulement sur
les retraites en allongeant l'âge de
départ mais également sur toutes les
administrations publiques par la
diminution du nombre de fonctionnaires
d'État hospitalier et territoriaux
hospitaliers territoriaux karaté se sont
eux c'est dans l'article liminaire qui
contribueront le plus à la diminution
des déficits publics merci chers
collègues
alors dessus
merci madame la Présidente oui puisqu'on
va voter cette article criminaire je
dois quand même rappeler quelques
interrogations auxquelles on n'a pas eu
de réponse pendant les débats et
pourtant on en a eu on a eu beaucoup
d'amendements qui ont soulevé un stand
de questions on a même eu des réponses
du ministre sur d'autres amendements
qu'on étudiera plus tard qui n'avait
rien à voir avec la discussion en cours
mais on avait eu on a quand même une
absence de réponse sur une un certain
nombre de choses notamment sur la
sincérité du véhicule législatif qu'on
utilise on va rappeler les la
chronologie le 29 novembre ici on voté
un plfs à peine un mois plus tard le 10
janvier ont présenté une réforme qui
concernait ce PLFSS mais donc on doit le
rectifier dans l'urgence parce que ça
facilite le gouvernement pour nous
corseter le débat et puis là on vient
d'apprendre que vous dites à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est mon collègue salvol
d'élite qui l'a dit
là on se base sur le texte de la
reprogrammation de la des finances
publiques votée au Sénat vous dit ça
l'Assemblée nationale et vous nous dites
nous ici non non ça sera le texte
initial tu n'as pas été voté à
l'assemblée donc on est sur quelque
chose d'assez flou d'assez insensé on a
un peu de réponse sur la trajectoire
d'embauche dans la fonction publique qui
a été soulevée par un centre de mes
collègues mais mon collègue sénateur du
Rhône n'a pas eu de réponse sur l'avenir
de la capitalisation on a on ne sait pas
si c'est le projet futur du gouvernement
comme ça a été soulevé par un centre de
mes collègues aussi et puis on a
toujours pas la réponse de mon collègue
jeunes sénateur Breuillet sur la note du
Conseil d'État que vous refusez de
rendre public donc on est encore un peu
sur notre fin dans le début de ces
débats je vous remercie madame ponce
merci madame la Présidente alors moi je
n'ai toujours pas de réponse sur le fait
que vous ayez que vous allez enlever
j'espère
les trois virgule un milliard des
mesures sociales qui sont à mensonges et
ramener donc vos mesures à 3 milliards
sur 18 milliards donc vous avez dit que
nous étions nous nous basons sur la loi
de programmation des finances publiques
ce texte qui prévoit dans ces articles
17 à 20 de cantonner les dépenses des
branches de la sécurité sociale et du
Fonds de solidarité vieillesse à 21,8%
du PIB de 2023 jusque jusqu'en 2025 dans
sa version du Sénat ça a été dit la loi
de programmation prévoyait un objectif
de réduction globale des effectifs de la
fonction publique de 5% soit 120000
postes cette réduction est c'est pour
l'avenir nos discussions
futures étant concordance avec la
convention EPR que vous favorisez
dans lequel vous vous basez qui que sur
lequel s'appuie le gouvernement et qui
prévoit un désengagement de l'État
brevant les recettes de la sécurité
sociale et justifiant la réforme injuste
dont on va discuter cette convention le
Pr
d'ailleurs un peu c'est comme le
nucléaire c'est pas une bonne c'est pas
c'est pas une bonne convention s'appuie
sur une baisse de la rémunération des
fonctionnaires ça a été dit de 11% et
une baisse des recrutements alors que si
aucun décrochage n'était organisé le
déficit serait réduit de 3 milliards en
conséquence donc nous ne voterons pas
cette cette article préliminaire et les
Français doivent savoir que la réforme
des retraites dont parle ici rejoint une
politique globale de stérilité qui va
aggraver l'offre des services publics
ils doivent savoir l'ampleur et la
teneur de ce projet délétère sur
l'ensemble des administrations publiques
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Madame A poursu poli
merci madame la Présidente Henri
sterniak membres des économistes
intérêts dans une note présentée
préalablement aux annonces du
gouvernement explique l'importance de la
politique d'emploi public pour le
financement des retraites le corps
reprend les hypothèses fournies par la
Direction du Budget le nombre de
fonctionnaires serait fixe sauf les
15000 emplois dans les hôpitaux promis
aux Grenelle de la santé la nécessité
d'embauche dans l'éducation la santé les
soins aux jeunes enfants et aux
personnes âgées dépendantes la culture
sont oubliées de 2022 à 2037 l'indice de
la fonction publique perdrait 8,3%
pouvoir d'achat alors que le pouvoir
d'achat dans le privé augmenterait lui
de
12,7%. aucune leçon n'est tirée de la
dégradation de l'attractivité des
emplois publics compte tenu de ces
hypothèses la part du traitement des
fonctionnaires dans la masse totale des
rémunérations passeraient de 10,5 en
2022 à 7,8 en 2037 je vous remercie
chers collègues la parole est à Madame
Ferret
merci madame la Présidente explication
de vote effectivement sur cet article
liminaire rappelez que contre la vie des
organisations syndicales et malgré
l'opposition des Français qui se
mobiliseront encore massivement mardi
prochain dans tous les territoires et ce
ne sera pas la fin du monde le
gouvernement s'obscine à vouloir reculer
l'âge légal de la retraite à 64 ans nous
nous opposons à cette réforme injuste
qui n'est pas utile en l'état et brutal
qui va pénaliser en priorité les femmes
et tous ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt cette réforme elle est
brutale car elle va s'appliquer
immédiatement dès 2023 la retraite c'est
une nouvelle vie elle se prépare elles
sont ici pour faire place à des projets
personnels familiaux et bien non ces
Français qui devaient partir à la
retraite cette année nous le pourrons
pas
puisque nous sommes ici pour débattre et
surtout pour dire la vérité aux Français
il faut avoir le courage de l'avouer en
réalité cette réforme va créer encore
plus de précarité et de pauvreté et
aussi sur cette réforme nous avons tout
entendu le président comme la première
ministre nous ont même expliqué qu'elle
permettrait de dégager des marges de
manœuvre pour financer d'autres
politiques publiques on en a parlé
depuis quelques heures maintenant parce
que c'est essentiel de dire aux Français
ce qui en est véritablement de cette
réforme ce qui nous ont dit ce que nous
avait dit démontre bien que le problème
n'est pas les retraites mais les
finances publiques car là encore comment
expliquer que ces économies sur le dos
des travailleurs changent que les
paramètres de nos finances publiques
quand on parle d'économiser 10 à 15
milliards par an tout ceci n'est pas
sérieux et encore moins de parler de
faillite à l'image du ministre Attal les
Français ne sont pas dupe lorsqu'ils
entendent parler de déficit abisseaux
pour faire croire que ces restrictions
s'imposeraient pour sauver le système la
réalité c'est plutôt que certains
déficits sont parfois volontairement
entretenus il en est ainsi de la non
compensation des allègements de
cotisations décidées par l'État pour la
sécurité sociale ainsi au travers de ces
arguments je dirais nous pourrions
discuter plus longuement les raisons
sont toutes claires pour expliquer que
nous voterons contre cet article ici
chers collègues la parole est à monsieur
le Président Kanner
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres
vous aurez compris que le groupe
socialiste écologiste républicain votera
donc contre cet article luminaire
et peut-être que ça convaincra certains
qui avaient déposé un abonnement de
suppression qu'ils n'ont pas voté j'ai
pas bien compris mais
ça regarde la majorité sénatoriale en
tant que tel simplement vous dire que
pour nous ce sera le premier acte
officiel pour refuser cette réforme
impopulaire je crois que tout le monde
peut en convenir
injuste parce qu'elle touche une
majorité de Français sans mettre à
contribution l'extrémité des Français
qui a profité de l'hyperm bouclier
social fiscal pardon de Monsieur
Macron et
inutile parce que nous sommes toujours
pas persuadés que c'est par cette
méthode qu'on pourra équilibrer le
système des retraites par répartition
j'en profite d'ailleurs pour rappeler
que en 2021 ce régime tant décrié à
dégager un excédent de 900 millions
d'euros
et qu'en 2022 il a dégagé un accident de
2 milliards d'euros certes je regarde
les courbes comme vous toutes et vous
tous et je sais que ça va pas durer mais
il peut y avoir des bonnes années c'est
le cas alors dans quel contexte
sommes-nous mes chers collègues
aujourd'hui viennent de tomber les
résultats
du de grandes entreprises françaises CGM
CMA
25 milliards d'euros
de bénéfices 25 milliards d'euros plus
que les 19 ou 20 milliards d'euros de
Total
vous vous obstinez à droite
et à la droite ici présente l'iséenne
vous obtenez à ne pas vouloir faire
contribuer ceux qui auraient les moyens
de contribuer pour équilibrer
globalement les dépenses publiques dans
notre pays et bien donc nous voterons
contre certains techniques liminaire
comme le signe de notre détermination
pour voter contre globalement cette
réforme des retraites
[Musique]
merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues de ce débat
et en particulier des interventions du
ministre des comptes publics tout à
l'heure nous avons bien compris
l'objectif de cette réforme faire des
économies financer les baisses d'impôts
qui ont été
[Musique]
aligner les unes avec les autres depuis
quelques années financer des
exonérations ou les allégements de
cotisations sociales qui ont été mises
en place progressivement et en
particulier lors de la loi sur le
pouvoir d'achat allaité dernier alors
voilà pour faire des économies
et bien c'est
900 000 personnes
qui doivent c'est une génération c'est
une année de départ en retraite c'est à
peu près 900 000 personnes et ben c'est
900 000 personnes à qui on va dire
désolé ça sera l'année d'après voilà
évidemment comme ça on fait beaucoup
d'économies on fait beaucoup d'économies
parce que on report on reporte des
pensions à payer et en plus comme on
pose des conditions complémentaires les
pensions seront plus faibles donc en
fait doublement des économies sur le
moment et après voilà c'est la seule
motivation que vous avez et je voudrais
dire à ce stade qui a d'abord une
conviction on l'a vu auparavant sur
l'assurance sur l'assurance chômage
si on veut maintenir un bon niveau de
protection sociale soldat d'abord être
l'affaire des partenaires sociaux et pas
celui de l'État dont on voit ce qu'il
fait avec la protection sociale un outil
pour mettre la main dessus et financer
ses déficits et ça n'est pas acceptable
et la conviction que j'ai aussi quand on
regarde l'évolution de ce que représente
les pensions dans le PIB en France
c'est-à-dire que ça ne va pas augmenter
contrairement à ce que vous dites ça ne
va pas augmenter et ça c'est une
préoccupation parce que compte tenu de
l'évolution de la population si ça
n'augmente pas ça veut dire qu'on va
revenir à une situation qu'on a connue
il y a 50 ou 60 ans que progressivement
les personnes de plus de 60 ans
redeviendront des personnes pauvres et
s'il faut une réforme des retraites
c'est une réforme qui répond à cette
demande pourquoi c'est comme ça parce
que les carrières sont de plus en plus
âgées parce qu'il y a de plus en plus de
polypes
merci Monsieur Lecomte la parole est à
Monsieur Marie
voilà il est 22h44 sur un thème de
public c'est là on le voit un la gauche
qui utilise toutes les armes
parlementaires du Règlement du Sénat
explication de vote scrutin public pour
ralentir l'examen de cette réforme et
d'ailleurs c'est parlementaire de gauche
qui se relaient entre les trois groupes
de gauche pour prendre la parole Audrey
vous êtes toujours dans l'hémicycle
dites-nous comment se passe en fait ces
prises de parole et bien Quentin chaque
sénateur a deux minutes pour défendre
son amendement ou pour expliquer son
vote s'il a s'il s'est inscrit pour le
faire évidemment les sénateurs de gauche
essaye de tenir au plus possible ces
deux minutes mais c'est deux minutes top
chrono d'ailleurs il y a deux
chronomètres ici dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat peut-être que vous les voyez aux
côtés de la présidente quand le temps
est dépassé elle les rappelle à l'ordre
gentiment ça se fait plutôt dans la
bonne ambiance jusqu'à présent mais
sachez qu'elle peut couper le micro du
sénateur qui parlerait trop longtemps ça
ça arrive évidemment très rarement autre
point les ministres peuvent répondre à
une prise de parole pour cela ils
doivent en faire la demande tout à
l'heure on a vu Gabriel Attal demander à
prendre la parole pour répondre sur un
point économique notamment et bien merci
Audrey pour toutes ces explications on
est donc dans les explications de votre
autour de l'article liminaire et donc la
gauche qui continue à bien présenter des
orateurs dans ses explications de votre
retour dans l'hémistice cyclable c'est
celle de la volonté d'appliquer à
l'ensemble de la fonction publique une
politique d'austérité depuis 2017 cette
politique d'austérité elle se coupe par
ailleurs à un démantèlement progressif
de la fonction publique en obligeant
l'ensemble des administrations publiques
de l'État la fonction publique
hospitalière la fonction publique
territoriale de recourir de plus en plus
fréquemment aux contractuel or c'est ce
qui déséquilibre aujourd'hui
les possibilités
d'abondement des systèmes de retraite
c'est ce qui explique aujourd'hui aussi
les difficultés de la CNR ACL et quand
on ajoute à cela le fait que le
gouvernement a séché les collectivités
c'est à Madame leanman
chers collègues beaucoup d'arguments
plaident déjà pour refuser cet article
luminaire
mais il faut bien regarder dans comment
se déroule ces successions de réforme
chaque fois le même scénario
d'abord on gonfle les déficits
on assèche les retraits les retraites on
assèche les recettes
conclusion le niveau des retraites et
l'accès à ses retraites se dégradent et
là arrive les publicités sur faites donc
vous n'aurez plus de retraite alors ça
donc prenez des assurances et le en
l'occurrence des fonds de pension et là
chers collègues de LR mais au moins vous
avez l'avantage de vous dévoiler c'est
comme d'habitude celle prétexte de
sauver le régime des retraites la
réalité c'est que vous voulez des
retraites minimales et une grande part
de capitalisation en tout cas croissante
je voudrais insister sur le fait que par
ailleurs vos calculs financiers sont
inexactes
outre le fait que vous asséchez et que
vous vous décidez pour des lustres que
la contribution de l'État ne va pas ne
va pas augmenter au nom de quoi vous
pouvez décider aujourd'hui qu'on va pas
augmenter le nombre de fonctionnaires
jusqu'en 2037 au nom de quoi tout ça est
très aléatoire mais surtout
mais surtout vous n'avez et là je vous
interroge monsieur le ministre
combien évaluez-vous le nombre de
seniors
supplémentaires qui vont être dans la
zone grise ni emploi ni retraite combien
il y aura-t-il de RSA combien y
aura-t-il d'ASS combien y aura-t-il de
seniors supplémentaires au chômage à ma
connaissance les administrations les ont
évaluées chaque année à 40000
supplémentaires dans chacune de ces
catégories si Madame Lindeman la parole
est au président Laurent
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
m'adresser à mes collègues LR avant que
nous passions au vote sur une merde ce
que vous êtes très nombreux mais
visiblement condamné au silence par un
coup de baguette magique du président
rotaïo j'imagine qui vous a demandé de
ne rien dire sur rien alors je voudrais
vous interpeller parce que après avoir
entendu le ministre à tal on a compris
que sur le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques c'est du bricolage intégral on
ne sait même pas ce que vous avez voté
si c'est utilisé ou pas respecté ou pas
à propos des règles européennes on sait
qu'on va devoir les changer qu'elle
n'existe pas mais on continue de les
utiliser à tort et à travers un de vos
collègues tout à l'heure Étienne blanc a
expliqué que l'article liminaire c'était
n'importe quoi et que d'ailleurs il ne
serait pas respecté à l'arrivée il a
d'ailleurs pas voté son propre
amendement mais sa salle regarde mais
tout ça ne vous ressemble pas jusqu'à
quand vous allez voter ce grand
n'importe quoi budgétaire c'est quand
même pas brillant pour des grand
spécialistes de la rigueur budgétaire
vous allez continuer à ne rien dire
alors nous ne sommes pas d'accord sur le
fond c'est clair vous voulez à tout prix
arriver au vote pour les 64 ans parce
que il y a ça qui a ça qui compte pour
vous mais jusqu'à quand vous allez
cautionner et la méthode du gouvernement
le 47 ans et tout ce qui va avec les
calculs fabriqués de toutes pièces du
gouvernement pour justifier
statistiquement son projet de réforme
est-ce que vous allez en un mot je vous
pose la question continuer à laisser
abaisser le Sénat de cette manière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres
cet article criminaire est essentiel au
fond il montre que cette réforme n'a
qu'un objectif faire baisser les
dépenses publiques pour respecter les
objectifs du pack de stabilité et de
croissance mais il n'est pas admissible
que cela se fasse au détriment de la
santé et de la qualité de vie des
Français à un moment de sa vie il est
bon de pouvoir penser que l'on arrête le
labeur pour vivre un autre rythme et
deux ans de plus à travailler ce n'est
pas rien surtout pour ceux qui sont les
plus abimés par le travail mais ces
décisions auront aussi d'autres
conséquences ces jeunes retraités se
sont eux qui font la richesse de nos
engagements associatifs ce sont souvent
eux qui sont les conseillers municipaux
qui nous élisent chers collègues ce sont
eux aussi qui s'occupent des petits
enfants quand hélas les places en crèche
manquent ce sont eux encore qui
s'intéressent à la santé de leurs
parents en grand âge parce que là encore
le manque de structure publique et
cruelle et donc tous ces éléments là ne
figurent pas dans le tableau de cet
article liminaire ils auront pourtant
des coûts sociaux et des coups dans la
cohésion sociale très lourd enfin je
voudrais redire monsieur le ministre
pourquoi ne publiez vous pas ce texte
la vie du Conseil d'État qui n'est pas
un avis mais qu'une note de synthèse et
qui permettrait qu'ici nous sachions
tous ce que vous savez tous parfaitement
chers collègues à savoir qu'on utilise
un véhicule législatif qui va empêcher
et corpseter un travail une réflexion et
un débat sincère sur les enjeux du
travail car oui derrière la question des
retraites il y a d'abord les enjeux du
travail et c'est d'abord de ça que nous
devrions parler lorsque nous abordons ce
débat donc monsieur le ministre je le
redis les parlementaires ont droit à une
information autre que la lecture des
journaux
la parole est à Madame le héros
j'ai également un doute sur la sincérité
budgétaire de cet article il fait état
d'une hausse de 400 millions d'euros de
la branche la branche vieillesse
correspondant à des mesures
d'accompagnement liés à la présence de
loi notamment relative à la pénibilité
toutefois pas de baisse de dépenses
observée ni de hausse de recettes
générée par les mesures de cette réforme
censée entrée en vigueur à partir de
septembre au cours du précédent
quinquennat le budget de l'État a été
imputé à hauteur de 50 milliards d'euros
par an suite à des baisses d'impôts au
profit des plus riches des grandes
entreprises suppression de l'ISF
création de la flat tact et maintenant
la fin de la CVAE le déficit prévu pour
2023 n'est pas la résultante d'un
déséquilibre démographique mais un choix
politique le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites prévoit un retour à
l'équilibre à horizon 2050 avec un
effort de l'État constant dans le
financement des retraites à hauteur de
2% du PIB alors qu'Emmanuel Macron
lui-même balayait la prétendue urgence
financière dans son programme de 2017 le
sauvetage du régime redevient la
justification centrale de la réforme
pourtant la santé financière du système
de retraite ne justifie aucunement le
recul de l'âge légal le départ à la
retraite et l'augmentation de la durée
des cotisations qui auraient des
conséquences sociales des astreuses les
projections du gouvernement reposent sur
la convention dite équilibre permanent
des régimes qui supposent d'une
diminution progressive de l'effort de
l'État dans le financement du système de
retraite découlant de la baisse de
l'emploi public dans l'emploi local
comme les employeurs publics ont des
taux de cotisations supérieures au
régime général du privé moins il y a de
fonctionnaires moins l'État participe au
financement du système de retraite et
plus son équilibre est menacé pour par
ce vote contre cet article préliminaire
nous manifestons donc notre opposition
générale au projet de réforme des
retraites
merci chers collègues la parole est au
président rénal
moi je voudrais dire à ce soir quand
même
que on est au début d'une phase d'études
de ce texte mais après une période tout
à fait particulière ça fait 6 ans déjà 6
ans qu'on nous parle de réforme des
retraites une paille je voudrais pas
qu'on oublie quand même que chaque fois
nous avons affaire à une réforme géniale
chaque fois
la réforme par exemple de la retraite à
point ça devait être ça devait être
génial ça devait tout régler ça implosé
en trois mois juste en réfléchissant un
peu en montrant que certaines
professions étaient totalement oubliées
juste les enseignants par exemple il y a
juste quelques millions d'enseignants
une paille bon et donc tout d'un coup ça
capote c'était génial ça a capoter
ensuite on nous dit deuxième mandat on
nous dit oui retraite à 65 ans retraite
de type paramétrique bon lance ça et on
commence à démarrer l'opération très
bien et puis on sent que ça prend pas et
ça prend pas parce que il faut une
majorité juste une paille faut une
majorité pour la voter et finalement on
conclut par quoi non plus par un projet
du gouvernement mais finalement par le
projet de la majorité sénatoriale c'est
quand même très particulier un
gouvernement qui fait ça d'ailleurs je
voudrais dire qu'au moment toute l'autre
jour de la de la DG moi je me suis
étonné que le président Retailleau ne
parle pas après les ministres voilà moi
je pense que quand on est quand on est
groupe coproducteur coproducteur on
assume cette coproduction je le regrette
je le regrette et puis ensuite quand
même on est passé de Bruno Le Maire qui
lisez la vérité ces budgétaires bon on
l'a fait taire on l'a dit non non c'est
pour le bien des retraités bon là on a
dit c'est trop tu vois ça a été démonté
et maintenant c'est purement puis ça
redevient budgétaire et nous cogner
la parole est à Monsieur symbole d'Ellie
oui merci madame la Présidente messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues il y a
aucun doute on votera compte parce que
et je vous avoue que je suis étonné du
blocage à 251 93 parce que quand même si
j'ai bien compris vous me dites si je me
trompe en particulier c'est l'état des
prévisions c'est l'état du sol
structurel et l'état de la prévision
donc c'est sérieux quoi comme dit le
ministre c'est crucial alors moi je vais
vous dire c'est que là on est dans une
logique alors soit on la partage à
totalement et on y va c'est-à-dire on
fait comme pour l'assurance chômage
version apocalyptique du gouvernement on
fait une réforme avec un excédent de 4,1
milliard mais ces catastrophique et on
fait perdre des droits aux travailleurs
et là c'est la même chose et là moi je
m'adresse à mes collègues de droite vous
nous répétez à chaque fois à chaque
projet de loi de finance vous les
communistes l'entreprise vous y
connaissez rien vous défendez pas
l'entreprise et ben moi je vous lance un
défi je vous lance un défi je vous lance
un défi
pareil avec la dette publique faites
comme dans les entreprises privées c'est
très simple je vous donne la méthode
vous allez soustraire les actifs vous
connaissez l'entreprise moi aussi je la
connais vous soustrayez les actifs et le
passif et qu'est-ce que ça s'appelle
dans le langage d'un patron ça s'appelle
le bilan de l'entreprise et bah donc
c'est très important l'article
criminaire parce que la dette publique
de la France c'est pas 112,5% de PIB
c'est 87% de PIB et là on a un problème
on peut avoir un avis différent sur
plein de sujets mais on peut pas
accepter qu'on nous vende des mensonges
et des comptabilités qui sont pas justes
voilà c'est ça le problème parce que
derrière c'est l'économie allez voir les
fonctionnaires vous croyez que je vais
faire comment dans mon département et
dans le vôtre quand il manque des
enseignants ils sont où là dans nos
débats et les contractuels dans la
fonction publique il y en a plus 600 000
vous savez ce que c'est leur vie 41%
sont CDD 68% des contrats de moins d'un
an dans ce qui verse à leur régime il y
a 25% dépend des contractuels de la
fonction publique
ils n'ont pas de retraite complémentaire
la parole
est à quelques minutes maintenant du
scrutin public sur l'article liminaire
alors Audrey il y a un point qui peut
interroger nos téléspectateurs c'est le
fait que les votes en scrutin public on
les voit notamment s'afficher dans
l'hémicycle il donne 343 votants alors
que l'on le voit derrière vous notamment
les missycle n'est pas plein ce soir et
oui Quentin est la raison et toute
simple un sénateur s'il est présent dans
l'hémicycle peut voter en théorie pour
la totalité de son groupe politique
c'est la raison pour laquelle tous les
sénateurs votent quand on regarde le
scrutin alors qu'en effet derrière moi
l'hémicycle éclaire semé même s'il y a
quand même un bon nombre de sénateurs
c'est différent à l'Assemblée nationale
car en 1993 Philippe Seguin qui était
alors président à limiter la délégation
à un seul vote par député résultat un
député ne peut voter que pour un seul de
ses collègues c'est la raison pour
laquelle ils sont plus nombreux dans les
muscles au moment des votes voilà des
règles
entre l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat
sur ses scrutin public un scrutin public
sur l'article liminaire qui est imminent
maintenant dans l'hémicycle et de
retraite et des systèmes de retraite et
donc en ce qui concerne le besoin de
financement pour en avoir une juste
appréciation il faut regarder donc à
court terme mais en moyenne terme et
aussi une tendance à long terme ainsi si
l'on considère à la fois un taux de
croissance de 1,3% je le disais un taux
de chômage de 7%. on peut dire alors que
le besoin de financement en 2027 7
milliards d'euros s'il est à maintien sa
participation 9 milliards d'euros s'il
est à réduit sa participation en 2040 4
milliards d'euros s'il est à maintien sa
participation 18 milliards d'euros s'il
est à la réduit et à long terme entre
une stagnation sans dérive d'une maison
de financement si l'état réduit sa
participation et une amélioration suivie
d'un accident de financement si l'état
maintient sa partie passion dit
autrement le besoin de financement du
système de retraite évolue au sein de
l'intervalle qui dépend directement des
choix politiques que fera l'État pour
toutes ces raisons et elles sont
nombreuses nous voterons effectivement
la suppression de cet article merci
chers collègues la parole est à Monsieur
l'URL
[Applaudissements]
les collègues ont tous donné les raisons
forts valables et légitime pour
voter contre cet article liminaire j'ai
une autre raison à Madrid ça à mes
collègues de la majorité sénatoriale
après six ans de prison ici je croyais
qu'il y avait quelques orgueil voire
quelques fiertés d'appartenir à cette
maison là pour de sombres calculs qui
sont les vôtres vous avez décidé
d'accompagner le gouvernement en
piétinant les lois du Parlement vous
avez l'impression que en faisant cet
abus de majorité j'allais presque dit
une majorité sénatoriale tyrannique
contre la minorité que nous sommes vous
servez vos intérêts mais oui alors que
vous aviez la possibilité
de 20 gouvernements qui crément votre
accompagnement de faire plier le
gouvernement et
je peux vous pourriez avoir une forme de
conservatisme éclairée je ne comprends
pas cet abaissement et cette faiblesse
parce que vous voulez prospérer vous
n'êtes pas au gouvernement vous pensez
que ce sera la retraite Retailleau
franchement je trouve ça un peu étonnant
après saison de présence la raison pour
laquelle je demande sur ceux de lucidité
pardonnez-moi j'espère que vous serez
pas blessé de dignité sénatoriale
la parole est à Monsieur Spido
[Musique]
merci chers collègues
il se trouve que je suis un je fais
parmi les anciens dans cette honorable
assemblée et très honnêtement c'est bien
la première fois en plus de 20 ans que
je vois un débat de cette qualité
alors je ne sais pas si vous vous rendez
compte que nous sommes en train à cette
heure-ci de donner la même impression
que le peuple français retient de
l'Assemblée nationale
ainsi à ceux-ci près
non attendez attendez à ceci près j'ai
entendu un journaliste tout à l'heure
dans la salle des conférences faire ces
observations et nous dire que finalement
ici au Sénat c'était l'obstruction
cordiale
je trouve que le mot était bien choisi
mais est-ce que vous rendez compte quand
même que de défendre 60 ou 80
amendements
identiques de les défendre tous les uns
après les autres mais quelle idée cela
donne aux Français qui sont très
soucieux de cette question des retraites
il y a un véritable problème alors
je ne sais pas ce que vous cherchez
enfin je le devine c'est finalement de
faire en sorte que nous n'arions pas à
la fin du débat et au vote de cette loi
peut-être mais de mon point de vue je
vous le dis très tranquillement mais
tout cela ne réhausse pas l'idée que les
Français peuvent se faire du Sénat alors
j'espère que vous allez vous ressaisir
merci
[Applaudissements]
alors pour répondre à Monsieur sido moi
je suis un jeune sénateur je pense ou
récent récent sénateur et et
pour tout vous dire nous dépôt nous
défendrons tous nos amendements c'est
notre droit le plus strict entre
parlementaire nous n'avons pas à
recevoir de leçon de qui que ce soit par
rapport à ça et nous le ferons d'autant
plus que depuis des semaines
des milliers et des milliers de Français
manifestent avec une dignité remarquable
vous ne les entendez pas donc nous nous
allons être la chambre déco des Français
et des françaises qui manifestent depuis
plusieurs semaines et que vous ne
souhaitez pas écouter et à travers ces
amendements c'est ça que nous défendons
et que nous continuerons à défendre
parce que cette réforme a les
profondément injustes aller profondément
brutale et c'est normal que nous soyons
là au combat avec tous les bancs de la
gauche pour défendre justement le peuple
français qui souffre qui va souffrir à
cause de ses réforme si elle est adoptée
et c'est l'honneur du Parlement
justement de pouvoir défendre ça dans
l'hémicycle dans un délai contraint que
vous acceptez vous-même que vous
acceptez qui est imposé par ce
gouvernement et vous auriez honneur
justement à intervenir dans ce débat
nous avons attendu une seule prise de
parole mais intervenez c'est votre
effort défendez là justifiez là
argumentez c'est ça le Parlement c'est
pas de se taire c'est pas d'avoir un bas
le bâillon Retailleau sur la bouche
c'est de pouvoir intervenir défendre vos
arguments faites comme Monsieur Pradier
lui au moins il a défendu des choses
contrairement à vous elle est où
l'époque elle est où l'époque de la
droite sociale gaulliste elle est où
celle-là elle a disparu en tout cas elle
est pas au Sénat et il y a un peu de
courage et défendez défendez vos
propositions
la parole madame rossignol
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi je remercie notre collègue bruno
Sido d'avoir d'abord d'avoir eu l'audace
de prendre la parole
puisque en effet c'est le pour la
première voie quasiment que nous avons
entendu et je voudrais lui dire assez
clairement que effectivement vous avez
raison
quelle image on les Français du
Parlement mais aussi du gouvernement et
globalement de ceux qui gouvernent ce
pays le dirige le représente alors que
depuis des semaines ils disent par tous
les moyens possibles mais par des moyens
pacifiques légaux il s'exprime dans des
manifestations qui sont des
manifestations aussi massives que
sereine il le s'exprime dans les
enquêtes d'opinion il s'exprime par des
mouvements de grève des mouvements
sociaux ils disent nous sommes
67 Français sur dix ne veulent pas cette
réforme cette Français sur 10 ne veulent
pas cette injustice alors après il y a
deux options dans l'exercice
démocratique
soit l'option qui a choisi le
gouvernement qui consiste à dire on vous
entend pas ou mieux vous n'avez rien
compris on va vous expliquer d'ailleurs
plus explique moins les gens comprennent
ou plutôt plus ils comprennent que ce
colora expliquer n'était pas la vérité
et puis il y a d'autres option qui
consiste à dire nous allons traduire au
Parlement ce mouvement pacifique de la
population et voyez-vous
vous ne nous est comme d'hab beaucoup
d'amendements oui c'est vrai mais vous
savez la conscient de 58 donne une
armurerie exceptionnelle aux majorité
gouvernementales et parlementaire au
gouvernement et à la majorité
sénatoriale pour tordre le bras des
oppositions et de la majorité des
français voire même je me demande si
elle Assemblée nationale ils ont pas eu
un problème de majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale pour recourir à la méthode
qu'ils ont choisie et nous opposition
nous avons quelques moyens nos
convictions notre parole nos droits
d'amendement et nous enduisons jusqu'au
bout
merci même la présidente monsieur
Gontard vous avez la parole monsieur le
Président oui merci madame la Présidente
moi de la même manière je remercie quand
même monsieur Sidot d'avoir pris la
parole parce que c'est vrai que c'est le
premier qui a le courage de l'apprendre
et allez deuxième en tout cas je en tout
cas je le remercie
et je pense que ça nous ça nous permet
ça nous permet quand même de dire oui
moi je j'écoute justement j'ai pas trop
pris la parole ce soir et j'écoute
j'écoute ce débat et je pense qu'au
contraire je pense que le Sénat je pense
que le Parlement ce soir il sort
particulièrement grandi parce que oui il
y a eu toute une liste d'amendements
effectivement qui pouvait se ressembler
l'ensemble des arguments qui ont été
donnés par tout le monde
avait une vraie argumentation mais en
face moi j'ai rien entendu des ministres
qui sont restés muets les seules
réponses qu'on a pu avoir c'est sur des
amendements qui sont qui vont arriver et
sur lequel on a même pas encore pu on a
comme débattre on a demandé des éléments
on les a toujours pas on nous renvoie
pareil je ne sais quand et puis de votre
côté cette réforme que vous voulez
co-construire cette réforme que vous
souhaitez de vos vœux qui est j'ai
l'impression votre seul projet votre
seul projet de faire travailler les gens
plus et je préfère travailler les gens
plus longtemps défendez là c'est ça le
Parlement c'est ça c'est qu'on débatte
c'est qu'on comprenne vos arguments
c'est qu'on comprenne aussi justement je
pense les erreurs que vous pouvez faire
alors que là voilà on a un parlement à
plat qui ne débat pas et puis derrière
ça il y a aussi ce fantasme de
l'Assemblée nationale on l'a eu hier
soir avec les ministres ont tenté
essayer de faire attention voilà essayer
de faire monter un petit peu la sauce et
puis là vous êtes un petit peu déçu en
fait vous êtes un petit peu déçu par la
qualité des débats qu'on peut avoir par
les arguments qu'on peut avoir alors moi
j'attends pas d'avoir la même qualité de
débat je vous attends prenez la parole
expliquez-nous votre projet et là oui on
aura du vrai débat et là oui le Sénat
sera mis en avant merci si monsieur le
Président Madame nolagontry vous avez la
parole
merci madame la Présidente c'est pour un
rappel au règlement fondé sur l'article
46 bis du règlement j'ai écouté monsieur
sido je suis stupéfaite parce que ce
débat est important et vous évoquez le
fait que les Français auraient s'ils le
suivait l'image d'un débat qui serait
d'aussi mauvaise qualité je le comprends
dans votre bouche que celui de
l'Assemblée nationale
et je pense que si c'est le cas c'est de
votre fête
parce que nous sommes dans une situation
où la majorité de cette assemblée ne
participe pas au débat et totalement
passive discute on ne sait pas très bien
pourquoi vous êtes là puisque de toute
façon monsieur Retailleau vote pour
l'ensemble de son groupe au point que
tout à l'heure certains auteurs
d'amendement de suppression de l'article
n'ont même pas pu le voter donc je pense
que c'est à vous de vous ressaisir de
participer au débat de dire pourquoi par
exemple vous vouliez maintenir l'article
liminaire pourquoi par exemple vous
souhaitiez laisser les termes de
Maastricht et pourquoi depuis le début
vous souhaitez défendre ce texte donc
nous retiendrons et nous le dirons et
nous le répéterons à l'extérieur qu'ici
dans cette chambre la droite majorité du
Sénat n'a jamais participé à ce débat et
a donc été totalement passive
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Fabien gay
merci madame la Présidente pour une
explication de votre merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur les ministres mes
chers collègues bon avec mes enfants à
la maison je joue au roi du silence à la
maison ça fait du bien mais dans
l'hémicycle c'est moins bien
et je le dis avec une pointe d'humour
mais faut qu'on fasse extrêmement
attention les uns et les autres
il faut
c'est pas faux
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas faux mais revenons à
l'essentiel je pense qu'il faut faire
extrêmement attention
il faut pas signer la branche sur
laquelle nous sommes assises j'ai écouté
assez attentivement hier chaque oratrice
et orateur sur ce qui s'est passé à
l'Assemblée nationale sur une caricature
de commande ouvrez s'organiser les
débats d'abord le droit d'amendement est
constitutionnel et ici nous sommes là
pour parler et pour faire la loi et pour
la fabriquer il faut une confrontation
d'idée et nous vous le disons chacun des
noms mais nous sommes prêts au débat
assez argumenté mais il faut que en face
aussi il y a une réaction sinon on va
passer 12 jours oui extrêmement
difficile pour les uns comme pour les
autres mais attention aussi si vous
continuez à dire attention pas
d'obstruction etc viendra une réforme
constitutionnelle moi je suis arrivé il
y a pas si longtemps que ça on avait
déjà deux minutes trente aujourd'hui
c'est plus de que deux minutes et en
faisant ce que vous êtes en train de
faire vous allez ouvrir la porte en
réalité à réduire le droit d'amendement
et c'est à dire si nous en venons sur
une réforme du Parlement c'est en
réalité nous mettre de plus en plus en
difficulté et ensuite ça sera réduire le
nombre de parlementaires etc etc donc si
on pas la branche agissons des bâtons et
argumenter puisque vous avez beaucoup
d'arguments pour la retraite à 64 ans
nous vous attendons chers
et ça monsieur vallée
saisir l'occasion de l'intervention de
notre collègue bruno Sido pour revenir
sur un état d'esprit sur un vote qu'on a
eu il y a quelques semaines et au cours
duquel je pouvais parfaitement
comprendre ces arguments là nous avons
des collègues qui nous ont expliqué de
l'autre côté de l'hémicycle qu'il n'y
avait pas d'un côté ceux qui pouvaient
être fiers de leur vote et ceux qui
devraient par définition avoir honte de
leur vote et bien de la même façon nous
sommes dans une assemblée où on pratique
j'espère une forme de confraternité je
le dis aussi à l'attention du
gouvernement il n'y a pas là des gens
bien élevés d'un côté et des gens qui ne
se comporteraient pas correctement ou à
qui on ferait par avance le procès
d'intention de ne pas bien se comporter
dans un débat l'obstruction par silence
ou l'obstruction mutique est aussi une
forme d'obstruction et c'est une forme
d'obstruction qui nous empêche
d'entendre les arguments des uns et des
autres parce que moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est pas de nous prendre par avance des
leçons de maintien ce qui m'intéresse
c'est d'entendre Bruno retaillod et pas
d'avoir l'impression d'entendre Nadine
de Rothschild nous sommes des gens polis
bien élevés mon collègue du département
de la Charente-Maritime qui siège dans
votre groupe et qui tu connais bien
c'est que je ne me mouche pas dans la
nappe quand vous croisez la présidente
assassie au restaurant du Sénat elle n'a
pas le couteau entre les dents et donc
je vous suggère tout de suite d'É
viter sur ce registre là parce que vous
viendrez d'autant plus vite sur les
arguments de fond et surtout je le dis
dans l'intérêt de notre haute assemblée
et pour que l'image que nous souhaitons
tous donner soit exactement celle qui
est prévue au sortir de ces débats ne
finissez pas par donner l'impression
d'avoir voulu donner la leçon alors
qu'en fait vous aurez fait en sorte que
le débat n'est pas lieu donc les leçons
de politesse et les leçons de maintien
on va les mettre de côté et ce qui nous
intéresse c'est des analyses de fonds et
c'est ce qu'attendent des Français qui
eux aussi dans les cortèges respecte les
parcours qu'on leur donne sans très bien
élevés ça veut dire bonjour madame au
revoir madame et veulent surtout savoir
si oui ou non on va passer à 64 ans
alors la parole est à Madame Lubin
[Applaudissements]
oui merci madame la Présidente moi après
l'intervention de notre collègue j'ai
juste une question à formuler tout le
monde sait tout le monde sait que vous
êtes très majoritaire ici et que vous
êtes très très d'accord avec la réforme
qui est proposée par ce gouvernement
tout le monde sait que vous avez négocié
avec le gouvernement pour que la réforme
qui sortira
de ce de cette hémicycle si elle est
votée soit tout à fait conforme à ce que
vous voulez alors ma question est simple
qu'attendez-vous de nous
que nous nous jouions pas notre rôle
d'opposant rien ouais je l'ai bien
entendu que nous nous jouions pas notre
rôle d'opposants et d'élus du peuple
c'est-à-dire que nous fermions
définitivement notre bouche au prétexte
que nous sommes minoritaires et que vous
avez déjà tout négocié c'est ça votre
conception du débat républicain
merci chers
[Musique]
collègues monsieur les ministres mais
mes collègues je partage évidemment les
propos qui ont été tenus ce sont
exprimés à l'endroit de nos collègues LR
ils l'ont fait dans le respect du du
hash chacun dans le respect des formes
ils ont effectivement évoqué le silence
assourdissant qui est le leur par
rapport à la défense de ce texte qu'il
porte en réalité je m'étonne également
fortement du silence du même silence de
nos collègues RDPI qui sont quand même
partie prenante et au combien
de ce que contient ce texte voilà je
crois qu'il n'a pas un parmi eux qui a
pris la parole
depuis ah si ça va venir peut-être voilà
donc c'était l'objectif c'est c'était
qu'on les entendent enfin dans ce débat
important
donc notre chambre a besoin voilà et
donc plus encore nos compatriotes ont
besoin ils nous écoutent il nous écoute
et je pense que jusqu'ici en tout cas
pour le groupe les groupes de gauche
dont je fais partie nous avons été à la
hauteur des enjeux du respect des
institutions et plus encore du respect
des Français
alors vous l'attendiez chers collègues
de gauche et je prends donc la parole
juste pour vous dire je pense que vous
nous reprochez en tout cas à la majorité
sénatoriale et à la majorité
présidentielle vous nous reprochez de ne
pas prendre la parole pour défendre nos
amendements pour défendre l'article
enfin pardonnez-moi on est à l'article
liminaire d'accord pardonnez-moi pardon
pardonnez-moi aussi de ne pas forcément
rebondir sur les lourdeurs que vous avez
à chaque fois répéter c'est-à-dire
l'article préliminaire enfin vous levez
fait trois fois de suite donc
effectivement je pense que ça me fait
rire que vous mais en l'occurrence je
pense que vous êtes assumé assumé une
obstruction raisonnable par rapport à
celle de l'Assemblée nationale ou
effectivement il y avait 20000
amendements là on est un peu moins un
peu moins de 5000 mais assumer d'être
dans une obstruction sur nos débats
parlementaires assumer en fait que vous
ne voulez pas je vous ai pas on me
pardonnez-moi mais moi en l'occurrence
je vous ai écouté quand vous hurliez à
chaque fois vos amendements donc
effectivement assumer d'être dans une
obstruction par rapport à vos
amendements quand on voit que sur la des
amendements de suppression alors que
vous avez l'habitude généralement de
grouper au sein du même groupe un
amendement de suppression vous faites 62
amendements de suppression pour un
article pardonnez-moi mais si c'est pas
de l'obstruction c'est quoi et quand on
a à chaque amendement de suppression les
mêmes explications de vote qui ont été
repris et tout c'est exactement la même
chose pardonnez-moi mais assumer assumer
simplement d'être dans l'obstruction
vous voulez qu'on ait le débat sur les
64 ans vous voulez qu'on ait le débat
sur les régimes spéciaux et bien
avançons continuons travaillons sur les
choses à acheter c'est ça aujourd'hui
que les Français veulent de nous c'est
pas l'obstruction qui a été celle qui a
été organisée à l'Assemblée nationale
ils veulent de nous qu'on puisse les
représenter il veut de nous qu'on puisse
voter et faire améliorer ce texte et pas
l'attitude que vous avez aujourd'hui
merci la parole est à Madame place dans
l'hémicycle depuis maintenant 15 minutes
nous étions à quelques amendements du
vote sur l'ensemble de l'article
liminaire le Sénat examiné effectivement
une trentaine d'amendements par heure
mais donc depuis 15 minutes
l'intervention d'un sénateur LR a
provoqué une levée de boucliers sur les
bancs de la gauche pour tout comprendre
on va rejoindre Audrey bettaz que
s'est-il passé Audrey et bien Quentin ça
fait suite à une intervention du
sénateur LR Bruno cidre il sont peu
nombreux les sénateurs LR à cette
exprimée depuis 17h on les compte sur le
doigt d'une les doigts d'une main il a
donc pris la parole pour dénoncer une
obstruction cordiale en reprenant vos
termes quand un Calmet il a dénoncé le
grand nombre d'amendements déposés par
les sénateurs de gauche critiquant un
spectacle je cite
identique à celui de l'Assemblée
nationale vous l'imag ça a suscité une
bronca dans les rangs de la gauche le
sénateur socialiste Yann chanterel a
répondu du tac au tac en disant nous au
moins nous débattons nous défendons les
Français vous aussi des battez faites
comme Aurélien Pradier elle est où la
droite sociale une référence évidemment
à Aurélien Pradier le député du LOSC qui
a pris position contre la réforme des
retraites qu'il juge injuste ça raviver
un petit peu les débats la gauche qui
appelle les sénateurs de droite à se
mobiliser à débattre qui appelle aussi
les sénateurs de la majorité qu'on n'a
pas entendu qu'on n'avait pas entendu
jusqu'à présent ça a donné lieu à une
prise de parole du sénateur yakovelli et
sénateur de la majorité qui s'est
exprimé pour la première fois ce soir
Quentin oui effectivement c'est naturel
retour dans l'hémicycle pour continuer à
écouter ces échanges injuste le
gouvernement mis sur cette réforme pour
améliorer la croissance mais on sait
très bien
les études macro économiques le montrent
que ce ne sera pas le cas qu'il y aura
une hausse du chômage du RSA et encore
davantage de personnes en grande
difficulté merci chers collègues la
parole est à Monsieur
[Musique]
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres chers collègues je vais
m'adresser à vous qui nous dit que nous
faisons de l'obstruction mais finalement
croyez-vous que ce soir vendredi soir
23h23 nous sommes nombreux à être
finalement heureux d'être ici content
d'être ici non nous sommes là parce que
nous avons un mandat nous avons un
mandat de nos électeurs qui nous ont
demandé de débattre de défendre des
idées et c'est ce que nous faisons
simplement moi ce soir personnellement
je préfère être auprès de mes enfants
vraiment ce soir particulièrement
particulièrement laissez-moi vous dire
quand même aussi que moi j'aimerais vous
entendre chers collègues de la majorité
sénatoriale j'aimerais vous entendre
parce qu'en fait nous allons bientôt
rentrer dans une période électorale il
va et si vous ne vous exprimez pas ici
clairement individuellement vous allez
pouvoir vous cacher derrière le propos
ah mais moi j'ai rien dit j'ai pas dit
que j'étais pour l'allongement de la de
l'âge de la retraite que moi j'étais pas
là que je ne suis pas favorable ou je ne
tenais pas le discours de de l'éloge de
la paresse parce que je vous imaginez
finalement on va côtoyer les mêmes
personnes je vous vois difficilement
dire à des gens qui vont vous sollicitez
comme nous sollicite nous non non mais
finalement toi certes à travailler dur
mais tu vas devoir travailler 2 ans de
plus ça va être compliqué pour vous
tenir de tenir ce discours là et ça va
être du coup plus simple pour vous si ce
soir vous ne dites rien et si pendant
ces 11 jours qui arrivent vous ne dites
rien et vous vous cachez derrière la
parole de votre président
ce collègue la parole est à Madame
Ferret pour un rappel au règlement
[Musique]
oui merci madame la Présidente je
voulais faire rappeler au règlement
selon l'article 44 bis et rappeler que
selon son premier alinéa le gouvernement
les sénateurs ont le droit de présenter
les amendements et des sous amendements
au texte soumis à discussion devant le
Sénat cela pour dire à notre collègue
Xavier iacovelli que nous ne sommes pas
dans l'obstruction nous sommes dans
l'exercice de notre fonction de
parlementaire de sénateurs que de
pouvoir présenter soumettre au débat des
amendements l'ennui il est vrai c'est
que tous les amendements toutes les
prises de parole sont de ce côté-ci de
l'hémicycle et comme mes collègues ont
déjà pu le dire regretter que de l'autre
côté de l'hémicycle bien il n'y ait pas
de du répondant on est là vraiment dans
un espace où la démocratie doit
s'exercer on doit confronter nos points
de vue et où nous pouvons échanger
encore une fois et argumenter sur ce
projet de loi alors nous amendements ils
ont tous été défendus par celles et ceux
qui les portaient avec des arguments et
des objets qui ont été complémentaires
les uns des autres et non pas
contrairement ce qui a été dit avec
exactement la même prise de parole pour
chacun et chacune d'entre nous peut-être
qu'on était nettiez-vous pas là pendant
ce débat en tout cas c'est vrai qu'on a
pas entendu de votre côté non plus de
prise de parole qui pouvaient soutenir
cette réforme et en particulier
l'article luminaire qui est tellement
important sur ce projet de réforme merci
acte tes données de ce rappel au
règlement la parole à Monsieur Lemoine
pour explication de vote
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente nous
sommes effectivement sur criminaire un
certain nombre d'enjeux financier ont
été exposés et il importe de voter cet
articleaires j'ai entendu sur certains
bancs le fait que les dépenses de
retraite restent restables j'ai le
rapport du corps entre les mains elles
vont augmenter dans un premier temps là
encore pendant quelques années et après
ce stabiliser mais elles vont se
stabiliser à quel prix le corps les cris
noir sur blanc il le dit c'est
principalement imputable à la baisse de
la pension moyenne relative donc ça
signifie ça signifie que effectivement
si elles sont stables c'est parce que
les pensions de retraite progresseront
moins vite que les revenus d'activité
est-ce qu'on veut se résoudre à ça non
nous avons besoin d'agir et c'est
pourquoi cette réforme est présentée
c'est pourquoi elle doit être débattue
il s'agit en rien d'être soumis à
Bruxelles ou à quiconque au contraire
lorsqu'on est souverain on prend
souverainement la décision justement de
ne va dépendre de tel ou tel marché de
tel ou tel instance et c'est donc un
choix souverain que nous faisons
justement pour ne pas avoir à payer x %
x milliards etc le financement de tout
cela et je dois dire que il est très
important
qu'effectivement ce débat se tienne dans
des conditions bien sûr de respect
mutuel je crois d'examen au fond des
amendements et je sais pas si c'est le
fait que chacun dépose le même
amendement qui va y aider on sait très
bien que dans nos débats il est possible
il est possible de croiser les regards
de croiser les arguments sans forcément
tous défendre le même amendement mais je
dis ça pourquoi parce que vous avez
peut-être
étude croisant le regard des Français
sur Jean-Luc Mélenchon Marine Le Pen
regardez le résultat de la stratégie de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il se fait ratatiner
par Marine Le Pen sur
les critères oui il est pas là mais il
mène la danse mais
merci la parole est à Madame Cohen
[Musique]
non il est merci merci Madame la merci
madame la Présidente alors effectivement
j'ai entendu obstruction cordiale de la
part de la gauche moi je suis très
choquée mes chers collègues je suis très
choquée parce que l'obstruction c'est
simplement le droit d'amendement des
parlementaires et vous devriez en être
fier et vous devriez le défendre
pour vous c'est la défense de nos
amendements en disant d'un air méprisant
qu'ils sont tous identiques mais vous
n'écoutez pas vous suivez un autre
programme ce soir les amendements que
nous présentons qui sont des amendements
de suppression sont tous argumentés en
vous donnant des exemples concrets
l'obstruction elle est réalisée par le
gouvernement et cette réforme qui est
unique et cette réforme que vous
soutenez parce que là il y a le
rassemblement des droites macronistes LR
sont triste tous ensemble pour s'en
prendre toujours au même ceux qui
souffrent ceux qui ont des carrières
pénibles les femmes ceux qui sont au
chômage c'est toi que vous attaquez mais
le gouvernement qu'est-ce qui fait il
fait les cadeaux toujours au même vous
voulez quand on vous propose d'autres
possibilités des financements
alternatifs ça n'est jamais bien l'arrêt
de des cotisations
comment des exonérations de cotisations
sociales 75 milliards ça ne vous
intéresse pas quand vous faites par
contre comme cadeau la suppression de la
cotisation sur la valeur ajoutée c'est
près de 5 milliards d'euros l'ISF 5
milliards d'euros le cice 20 milliards
d'euros et la fraude fiscale mes chers
collègues c'est 80 à 100 milliards
d'euros de cadeaux ça veut dire 5 à 9
fois le montant prévisionnel du déficit
annuel de l'assurance vieillesse alors
quand on veut on peut sans en prendre
aux gens qui travaillent et qui nous
regardent et qui sont heureux de voir
des parlementaires dignes qui les défend
si chers collègues la parole est à
Madame Artigalas merci madame la
Présidente moi je vais aussi Dris
répondre à quelques attaques qu'ils ont
été faites je voudrais répondre à
Monsieur yakovelli je crois que nous
avons on ne peut pas nous reprocher
d'examiner de prendre du temps pour
examiner et exposer des arguments contre
cet article liminaire qui est quand même
le cœur de la loi ou détriment
soi-disant d'autres articles plus
importants c'est quand même les éléments
financiers et je redis quand même que
sur nous nous avons pour chaque
amendement deux minutes pour les
défendre or vous avez bien vu tous tous
les arguments financiers tous les
chiffres que nous ont permis d'amener
tout ce que nous avons ce que tous les
amendements que nous avons déposés du
coup nous avons bien plus de temps pour
exposer effectivement l'iniquité de
cette loi et je vais vous dire vous vous
indique que les journalistes parce qu'on
fait de l'ostruction mais nous nous
avons eu de nombreux messages de nos
concitoyens qui regardent ces débats et
qui sont très contents grâce à ce que
nous disons d'apprendre des choses sur
cette loi et de se rendre compte à quel
point parfois les chiffres avancés par
le gouvernement peuvent être ne peuvent
ne sont pas bons et ensuite pour revenir
on a bien montré monsieur Lemoine aussi
la question c'est la question des
recettes nous avons eu l'occasion de
vous donner plein d'arguments pour voir
comment est-ce qu'on pouvait augmenter
les recettes de l'aide de ce régime de
retraite et je crois que là on n'est pas
d'accord là-dessus mais nous nous
donnons nous aussi dans nos éléments une
autre position nous avons d'autres
moyens pour retrouver un équilibre de
cette de cette le système de retraite
merci chers collègues la parole et
Monsieur
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
j'ai entendu deux qualificatifs tout à
l'heure un collègue parlait
d'obstruction cordiale et le second a
parlé d'obstruction raisonnable je
considère que ce que nous faisons ici
s'appelle tout simplement la démocratie
ça s'appelle un travail d'opposition
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
l'opposition hier vous l'étiez peut-être
que le demain vous le serez vous à
nouveau et ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui les droits que nous
défendons aujourd'hui vous en
bénéficierez le jour où vous serez vous
aussi dans l'opposition tout à l'heure
collègue comparé nos travaux avec ceux
de l'Assemblée nationale
comparaison
ici
personne télémistes et c'est très bien
ainsi parce qu'ici au Sénat nous avons
le culte du respect des adversaires le
culte du respect des ministres le culte
de la nuance et chacun et chacune
d'entre nous si effort c'est si emploi
pour le reste le projet de loi qui nous
est présenté finalement c'est le projet
de loi de la majorité sénatoriale par
procuration le gouvernement le porte par
procuration vous devriez chers collègues
de la majorité et trouver quelques
motifs de satisfaction dans votre
stratégie d'influence a réussi vous avez
réussi à influencer le gouvernement qui
a repris à son compte ce que vous
vouliez faire depuis tant et tant
d'années réjouissez-vous
revendiquez cette victoire symbolique et
politique et vous messieurs les
ministres vous chers collègues de la
majorité présidentielle assumait le fait
assumer cette jonction entre les deux
droites la droite sanatoriale la droite
présidentielle mais ni les un ni les
autres ne veulent assumer cette jonction
parce que dans quelques semaines les
collègues de la majorité sénatoriale
iront voir les grands électeurs et parmi
les grands électeurs il y a des
caissières parmi les grands électeurs il
y a des Atsems parmi les grands
électeurs il y a des hommes et des
femmes concernés par la pénibilité ce
sont à ces personnes là que vous allez
rajouter
200 au compteur je commençais par les
assumer ici parce que vous aurez réalisé
sur le terrain
procéder au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert
voilà on l'avait presque oublié mais
depuis une vingtaine de minutes
effectivement on s'approchait de la fin
de l'examen des amendements autour de
l'article liminaire effectivement il y a
eu cette parenthèse autour de cette
expression de d'obstruction constructive
mais donc on est arrivé au bout de ces
amendements et puisque la gauche
souhaite supprimer l'article liminaire
de ce projet de loi de réforme des
retraites et donc il y a un scrutin
public c'est à dire qu'on va encore une
fois avoir cette cartographie de
l'ensemble de l'hémicycle qui vote
autour de cette suppression et on
devrait sans surprise avoir le même
clivage très net entre la gauche et la
droite sénatoriale retour dans
l'hémistique pour écouter le résultat du
scrutin
personne
le scrutin qui est en cours c'est à dire
que vous voyez il y a un huissier qui se
trouve devant la tribune qui est bien
attend que tout les groupes politiques
et votés qui va pouvoir faire signer à
la présidente de séance que plus
personne ne demande à voter
voilà et donc maintenant l'ordinateur va
pouvoir donner le résultat du scrutin
dans quelques secondes alors le résultat
nombre de votants 342 exprimés 341
pousse en 50 contre 91 l'article
liminaire est adopté
nous passons donc première partie trois
amendements faisons l'objet d'une
discussion commune le
3394 madame pensez mange
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues c'est amendement est un
amendement de clarté et de sincérité sur
le fait que la réforme ici présentée
repose à 100% sur les travailleurs
aucune contribution n'est demandé aux
employeurs à part la mise en place de
cette index senior dont il est fort
probable qu'ils finissent par
disparaître après le passage au Conseil
constitutionnel et qui de toute façon
n'est pas contraignant aucun effort
n'est demandé aux revenus au patrimoine
alors que selon l'INSEE en 2015 10% des
ménages français ont un patrimoine net
supérieur à
534000 euros et alors que 2% des plus
grandes fortunes de France et qui valent
au les taxer à 2%, les plus grandes
fortunes équivaut au déficit des
retraites et qui pourrait alimenter le
fond de réserve des retraites vous avez
participé à leur enrichissement nous
sommes pour qu'ils prennent la part de
l'effort
l'ensemble de cette réforme donc repose
sur les travailleurs qui n'ont imposent
deux ans de plus alors que de multiples
solutions existent dont l'augmentation
des cotisations pour lesquelles
messieurs les ministres 59% des Français
sont favorables selon l'ifope contre
l'allongement de deux ans de leur durée
de travail et deux tiers des jeunes
selon le chercheur Michael Zemmour et le
corps s'est augmentation serait de 28
euros pour un salaire moyen d'ici 2027
sachant que ce même salaire augmenterait
de 128 euros d'ici là mais s'il faut
éviter la perte de pouvoir d'achat des
plus modestes point qu'on pourrait sur
lequel on pourrait se rejoindre alors
l'augmentation des cotisations sur les
hauts salaires est possible d'autant que
le CAE lui-même recommandait la fin des
baisses de cotisation pour les salaires
au-dessus de 1,6 SMIC pour leur faible
efficacité même leur nom efficacité
merci chers
collègues
3531 madame ponce c'est toujours vous
merci madame la Présidente alors le
présent amendement relève du constat et
du diagnostic partagé par toutes les
organisations syndicales comme par les
rapports évaluant déjà les effets de la
loi de prolongation précédente 2017
cette réforme frappe tous les
travailleurs mais encore plus les plus
modestes et les femmes outre l'extension
du sas de précarité de pauvreté pour les
seniors qui sont ni en emploi ni en
retraite la réforme va impacter aussi la
durée de retraite des plus précaires je
rappelle que l'INSEE in aide le corps
ont unanimement constaté une stagnation
des gains d'espérance de vie qui ne sont
plus tirés que par la baisse de
mortalité des plus de 70 ans je rappelle
que selon l'adresse les réformes
cumulées entre 2010 et 2015 ont déjà
contribué à faire baisser la durée de la
retraite de près de 7% entre la
génération de 2050 et celle de 2080 et
de façon très différen
alors que la durée moyenne de la
retraite était de 25 ans et demi avant
la réforme
Sarkozy elle est de 24 et demi
aujourd'hui donc elle a diminué d'un an
et devrait descendre à 23 ans en 2030 en
projection avec cette réforme c'est donc
une marche tout simplement en arrière et
selon les chercheurs
Ulysse le skin et Julien Blasco de
l'Université de Dauphine et Nanterre la
réforme envisagée diminuera la durée de
retraite de l'ensemble de la population
mais plus fortement des plus pauvres
selon leurs études et 5% entre
l'espérance de vie entre les 5% les plus
aisés 5% les plus pauvres c'est déjà 13
ans selon l'Insee alors que l'espérance
de vie en bonne santé entre un cas est
un ouvrier et de 11% selon le skin les
plus pauvres vont perdre jusqu'à 14% de
la durée de leur retraite avec cette
réforme les mesures d'atténuation que
vous proposez de cette brutalité que
vous appelez mesure sociale n'y
changeront malheureusement rien et à
Forterie rien pour la très grande
majorité des carrières longues dont le
départ entier
pour défendre le 2188 il est retiré nous
passons donc à la vie de la Commission
sur des les deux amendements restants
donc de Madame ponce
[Musique]
oui je réponds à ma collègue Raymonde
poncemont je peux lui dire que en fait
la première partie s'intitule
disposition relative aux recettes et à
l'équilibre de la sécurité sociale pour
l'exercice 2023 on sent bien que c'est
une consonance normée et que ça ne peut
pas être changé surtout avec des
consonances politiques telles que vous
les proposez donc c'est un avis
défavorable merci madame le rapporteur
avis du gouvernement
je vous remercie je mets donc
monsieur Ferro pour explication de vote
merci madame la Présidente c'est dommage
que pour une fois que la majorité
sénatoriale avait un amendement qui soit
retiré avant d'être présenté ça nous
aurait permis d'en discuter mais du coup
je vais parler des deux amendements de
notre collègue Raymonde ponts et Monge
et c'est dommage que Vincent Delahaye
notre collègue Vincent de laine ne soit
pas là parce que souvent lorsqu'on
discute du projet de loi de finances ou
d'un projet de loi de finance
rectificatif il propose un amendement
pour que le titre de la première partie
ne soit plus disposition relative aux
recettes et à l'équilibre financier mais
relative aux recettes et au déséquilibre
financier
il le présente en disant qu'il faut
mettre le titre de la première partie on
adéquation avec la réalité et bien ce
que nous propose les deux amendements
33-84 et 35 31 c'est de mettre certes
avec un peu d'humour le titre de la
première partie en adéquation avec la
réalité donc je pense que nous pouvons
tout à fait le voter
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres bien évidemment je voterai
l'amendement de ma collègue ponçait
Monge qui nomme les choses car mal les
nommé vous savez que ça coûte toujours
très cher 17% des Français trouvent
juste cette réforme
79%, la trouve injuste et je veux dire à
mes collègues de la majorité sénatoriale
que je reconnais leur courage de
défendre leur position alors que 59% de
leurs électeurs trouvent cette réforme
également injuste
c'est une réalité que les tous les
sondages dont tous les sondages
témoignent 70% des Français par ailleurs
trouvent cette réforme pas claire sans
doute en partie en raison de la non
présentation de la note de synthèse du
Conseil d'État
au fond le gouvernement continue à
cacher des éléments des données
financières c'est une ruse de procédure
pour empêcher un débat sincère et ça
n'est pas acceptable monsieur le
ministre je vous redemande de produire
aux yeux de tous nos concitoyens cette
note de synthèse du Conseil d'État
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
président rénal
oui Féro là évoqué mais sincèrement moi
je regrette qu'on peut pas discuter de
l'amendement de m'en envoyer et de ses
médecins de ses collègues mais peut-être
quand même a-t-on le droit de lire la
première phrase sans la discuter sans la
commenter la réforme des retraites il
nous est proposé ne va pas résoudre la
question du financement de notre système
de retraite par répartition ni un moyen
terme ni à long terme
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que vous vous exprimez peu
mais vous écrivez bien
et
sincèrement on ne pourrait pas mieux
démonter cette réforme qu'avec cette
phrase je crois que certaines d'entre
vous ont une lucidité particulière et je
voulais vraiment l'apprécier et vous
dire
ça pleine finalement
c'est que depuis 5 ans vous déposez un
abandon d'appel on le sait tous pour la
retraite on sait bien que la retraite 64
ans se fait pas par un amendement dans
le plfs mais
ok dommage c'est que vous ayez perdu 5
ans chers collègues pour déposer
quelques amendements d'appel sur les
vraies questions c'est-à-dire comment on
fait sur l'égalité des salaires hommes
femmes qui permet d'augmenter les
recettes comment on fait pour que les
seniors après vous proposez maintenant
quelque chose ben il est bien tard ça
fait cinq ans quand même temps que votre
amendement vous auriez dû proposer des
solutions pour augmenter les recettes
c'est là qu'on vous attendez c'est là
qu'on vous attend toujours d'ailleurs
parce qu'on voit rien arriver bon mais
voilà donc c'était un très bel
amendement à Monsieur reta vraiment vous
n'avez pas été gentil de retirer cet
amendement de grande qualité merci chers
collègues
il est à 23h47 nous sommes en direct sur
l'antenne de Public Sénat pour tout
comprendre sur les enjeux de cet examen
on va rejoindre Audrey vettaz question
toute simple Audrey on a voté l'article
limitée
donc examiné depuis trois heures on
pourrait s'attendre à être à l'article 1
ou en sommes-nous exactement Audrey et
bien quand un comme vous l'avez dit
l'article liminaire le préambule de ce
projet de loi vient d'être voté et comme
hier on a observé comme à chaque fois la
même dynamique de votre on a environ 90
voix ce sont les voix de la gauche ils
ont voté contre cet article liminaire
sur lequel ils avaient déposé de très
nombreux amendements pour le critiquer
et on a environ 250 voix ce sont celles
de la droite et du centre qui ont voté
en faveur de cet article pour son
adoption l'article a donc été adopté
désormais il y a plusieurs amendements
qui sont déposés plusieurs prises de
parole de la gauche
prestige le manque de débat avec les
sénateurs de droite les sénateurs de
droite qui sont en effet très peu
nombreux à avoir pris la parole depuis
17h il est donc bientôt minuit et vous
l'avez rappelé Quentin on a toujours pas
commencé à étudier l'article 1 celui sur
la suppression des régimes spéciaux
encore quelques amendements quelques
prises de parole on pourrait peut-être y
arriver à suivre donc voilà le suspense
est entier sur Public Sénat retour dans
l'hémicycle je suis vraiment
par l'amendement de notre collègue
Valérie Boyer parce qu'en fait ça va
dans le sens de ce que je disais hier je
parlais de la démographie
il y a justement il y a une quinzaine de
jours déjà lors des questions au
gouvernement mais là je trouve que
Valérie Boyer a fait quelque chose
d'extraordinaire c'est vraiment dommage
qu'elle n'est pas pu défendre parce que
je l'aurais probablement voté parce
qu'elle parle effectivement la situation
des femmes mais on dit femme qui sont en
âge de procréer et qui voudraient faire
des enfants et travailler aussi et hier
encore je le disais j'ai une seule en 4
minutes mais j'ai parlé de la
démographie j'ai parlé de la situation
des femmes et de la précarité également
merci Valérie Boyer pour ce que vous
avez fait malheureusement
je ne suis pas d'accord avec le fait que
vous ayez évidemment
arrêtez dans votre belle lancée parce
que vous l'avez pas présenté mais
franchement les arguments sont très très
bons et franchement j'aurais pu faire le
même merci
merci chers
je réagis après l'intervention de notre
collègue le moine qui a bien du courage
pour essayer de trouver quelques
éléments qui comme une rustine dans un
système de en train d'être
détérioré pourrait rattraper la donne il
nous a dit tout à l'heure et en cela je
rejoins l'amendement de Madame Pons
il nous a dit tout à l'heure vous allez
vous avez baissé les retraites avec la
loi Touraine vous certains ont baissé
les retraites avec la loi Touraine les
les
et avec notre réforme ça va pas être le
cas d'un manque de chance ça va être
pire c'est à dire le niveau des
retraites va considérablement baisser et
en tout cas si on compare le ratio entre
les retraites et les salaires
je rappelle que le et pourquoi parce que
plus vous accélérez la réforme Touraine
plus vous mettez une accélération sur la
baisse des retraites ce qui va avoir
lieu c'est que la projection 1% c'est à
dire celle du corps la potion moyenne
passerait de 50 % du salaire moyen en
2021 à 42% en 2050 on est votre réforme
accentue encore ce phénomène il faut le
dire aux Français oui c'est contre les
travailleurs non seulement ils vont
travailler plus mais leur retraite va
considérablement baisser et d'ailleurs
puisque vous nous donnez toujours les
exemples étrangers je vous rappelle
qu'en Allemagne le taux de retraite ne
dépense même à la fin des temps de
cotisations ne dépense jamais 50% des
revenus des actifs et vous avez un pays
où le nom de retraités pauvre ne cesse
de s'accroître alors votre modèle certes
la France est généreuse mais surtout la
France elle est respectueuse de la
dignité humaine et faire que les
retraités
la parole est à Madame ponce
oui alors merci notre collègue Lemoine
de prendre la parole alors effectivement
il parle de l'élargissement des départs
anticipés pour carrière longue et
d'ailleurs de la création de des super
carrières longues il parle aussi de la
routière de comment dire le fait de
vouloir favoriser les carrières longues
enfin les retraites progressives excusez
moi les retraites progressives tout
comme il aurait pu parler que ils vont
revaloriser de 0.0 c'est important à 100
les minimas contributifs mais sur ces
trois points il oublie de préciser une
chose contre deux ans de travail de plus
enfin
la fameuse départ anticipée pour
carrière longue qui avait été obtenu à
60 ans quand on est passé à 62 ans et
bien passe à 62 ans quand on passe à 64
et vous envisagez peut-être dans cinq
ans de passer à 64 quand on passera à 66
donc vraiment à chaque fois dites nous
revalorisons les minimas contributifs de
0 beaucoup 0 à 100 contre 2 ans de
travail en plus nous favorisons la
retraite progressive mais qui appartient
de 62 ans désormais nous enfin heureuse
favoriseront les départs anticipés pour
carrière longue mais là aussi deux ans
plus tard
mais la parole oui merci madame la
Présidente simplement je remercie madame
Lindman qui connaît bien ses dispositifs
et qu'il y a bien exprimé la réalité de
la situation elle a bien dit le fait
d'étendre la réforme Touraine arrive à
baisser les pensions c'est bien ça
l'équilibre et effectivement on sait
très bien que la réforme Touraine en
allongeant la durée de cotisation sans
bouger à l'âge fait que les retraites
moyennes vont baisser de 300 euros dans
quelques années le fait de décaler l'âge
évite de partir avec une décote et c'est
la raison pour laquelle ça augmente les
pensions de retraite en plus vous avez
des années supplémentaires qui
permettent qui permettent effectivement
de faire en sorte que les retraités
bénéficient d'une meilleure retraite
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
expliquons depuis quatre ans qu'il faut
être attent à ces deux piliers qui
constituent notre système de retraite le
pilier de la durée qui protège ceux qui
commencent tôt le pilier de l'âge qui
protège ceux qui commencent tard et si
vous ne jouez pas l'articulation avec
les deux vous avez un système contenu de
la démographie contenu du nombre d'entre
qui diminuent de plus en plus compte
tenu de la longévité qui fait que la
durée de retraite augmente de plus en
plus qui va au déséquilibre le plus
complet si nous ne prenons pas nos
responsabilités aujourd'hui on ne
travaillera pas jusque 64 ans nos
enfants dans quelques années
travailleront jusque 65 ans si nous
pouvons si nous ne prenons pas nos
responsabilités aujourd'hui nos enfants
envahiront pas 43 ans il travailleront
45 à 46 ans ce sera le seul ouais façon
d'équilibrer le dispositif alors mes
chers collègues nous aurons l'occasion
de discuter de cela pendant
plusieurs jours et c'est la raison pour
laquelle face à cette demande
supplémentaire d'un effort collectif le
Sénat va vous proposer des mesures de
justice sociale complémentaires
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur Marie
[Applaudissements]
merci Madame présidente
monsieur le rapporteur vous devez nous
expliquer que vous allez nous faire des
propositions
et que dans l'état actuel de la réforme
les retraités gagneraient plus
je vais vous parler
de quelques-uns nos concitoyens quelques
millions de nos citoyens ceux qui
aujourd'hui ont 60 ans et qui pour un
tiers d'entre eux ne sont ni en emploi
ni à la retraite mais soit au chômage
soit au revenu de solidarité active soit
en invalidité soit en congé de maladie
à 61 ans ils sont 61% à être dans cette
situation à 62 ans ils sont
73,6% à être dans cette situation alors
imaginez combien ils seront à 63 ans et
combien ils seront à 64 ans et si pour
eux le fait d'attendre encore deux ans
pour sortir de la précarité et
véritablement une avancée sociale
allez quelques minutes avant minuit on
va faire le bilan de cette première
après-midi d'examen des articles et
amendements de la réforme des retraites
ici au Sénat Audrey on vous retrouve
dans la tribune de presse de l'hémicy
que retenez-vous de ces 5 premiers
heures de première heure de débat sur
les articles amendements Quentin
quelques chiffres deux motion une
dizaine de rappels au règlement et
plusieurs dizaines d'amendements déposés
sur le seul article liminaire la gauche
déploie aujourd'hui sa stratégie pour
ralentir les débats officiellement les
sénateurs de gauche estiment être dans
leur rôle en déposant tous ses
amendements au nom des Français en
coulisses certains de ces sénateurs de
gauche nous confient qu'ils ne veulent
pas que l'article 7 celui sur
l'allongement de l'âge de départ en
retraite soit votée avant la grande
journée de mobilisation du 7 mars les
débats se sont animés vers 23h30 après
la prise de parole d'un sénateur LR
brune aussitôt qui a fustigé un
spectacle similaire à celui de
l'Assemblée nationale la gauche a
répondu en appelant la droite et la
majorité présidentielle à débattre à
débattre face à la gauche Quentin un
bilan il est bientôt minuit et nous
n'avons toujours pas commencé à étudier
l'article 1 celui sur la suppression des
régimes spéciaux merci merci Audrey
voilà pour le début de l'examen des
articles et amendement de la réforme des
retraites il en reste exactement au
moment où je vous parle
3661 à examiné d'ici bien sûr le 12 mars
avec d'ailleurs des séances de nuit
comme vous venez de le vivre sur le
public Sénat également des séances le
week-end d'ailleurs je vous donne
rendez-vous demain ce sera donc samedi
matin 9h30 sur cette antenne sur ce
plateau de la salle des conférences très
belle nuit
[Musique]
les 5 millions de Français qui
s'apprêtent à quitter le front on